part three the process of
individuation by ml fund france
the pattern of psychic growth
at the beginning of this book dr c g
young
introduced the reader to the concept of
the unconscious
its personal and collective structures
and
its symbolic mode of expression once one
has seen the vital importance
that is the healing or destructive
impact of the symbols produced by
the unconscious there remains the
difficult problem of interpretation
dr young has shown that everything
depends on whether any particular
interpretation
clicks and is meaningful to the
individual concerned in this way
he has indicated the possible meaning
and function of dream symbolism
but in the development of jung's theory
this possibility raised another question
what is the purpose of the total dream
life of the individual
what role do dreams play not only in the
immediate psychic economy of the human
being
but in his life as a whole by observing
a great many people
and studying their dreams he estimated
that he interpreted at least
eighty thousand dreams jung discovered
not only that all dreams are relevant in
varying degrees to the life of the
dreamer
but that they are all parts of one great
web
of psychological factors he also found
that on the whole
they seem to follow an arrangement or
pattern this pattern
jung called the process of individuation
since dreams produce different scenes
and images every night
people who are not careful observers
will probably be unaware of any pattern
but if one watches one's own dreams over
a period of years and studies the entire
sequence
one will see that certain contents
emerge disappear and then turn up again
many people even dream repeatedly of the
same figures
landscapes or situations and if one
follows these through a whole series
one will see that they change slowly but
perceptibly
these changes can be accelerated if the
dreamer's conscious attitude is
influenced by appropriate interpretation
of the dreams and their symbolic
contents
thus our dream life creates a meandering
pattern in which individual strands or
tendencies become visible
then vanish then return again if one
watches this meandering design over a
long period of time
one can observe a sort of hidden
regulating or directing tendency at work
creating a slow imperceptible process of
psychic growth
the process of individuation gradually a
wider and more mature personality
emerges
and by degrees becomes effective and
even visible to others
the fact that we often speak of arrested
development
shows that we assume that such a process
of growth and maturation
is possible with every individual since
this psychic growth cannot be brought
about by a conscious effort of willpower
but happens involuntarily and naturally
it is in dreams frequently symbolized by
the tree
whose slow powerful involuntary growth
fulfills a definite pattern the
organizing center
from which the regulatory effect stems
seems to be a sort of nuclear atom in
our psychic system
one could also call it the inventor
organizer and source of dream images
jung called this center the self and
described it as the totality of the
whole psyche
in order to distinguish it from the ego
which constitutes only a small part of
the total psyche
throughout the ages men have been
intuitively aware of the existence of
such an
inner center the greeks called it man's
inner diamond
in egypt it was expressed by the concept
of the ba soul
and the romans worshiped it as the
genius native to each individual
in more primitive societies it was often
thought of as a protective spirit
embodied within an animal
or a fetish this inner center is
realized an exceptionally pure
unspoiled form by the nascapi indians
who still exist in the forests of the
labrador peninsula these simple people
are hunters who live in isolated family
groups so far from one another that they
have not been able to evolve tribal
customs or collective religious beliefs
and ceremonies
in his life-long solitude the nazcappy
hunter has to rely on his own inner
voices and unconscious revelations
he has no religious teachers who tell
him what he should believe
no rituals festivals or customs to help
him along
in his basic view of life the soul of
man is simply an inner companion whom he
calls my friend or mr pio meaning
great man mr pio dwells in the heart
and is immortal in the moment of death
or shortly before
he leaves the individual and later
reincarnates himself in another being
those nascapi who pay attention to their
dreams and who try to find their meaning
and test their truth
can enter into a deeper connection with
the great man
he favors such people and sends them
more and better dreams
thus the major obligation of an
individual mascot
is to follow the instructions given by
his dreams
and then to give permanent form to their
contents in art
lies and dishonesty drive the great man
away from one's inner realm
whereas generosity and love of one's
neighbors and
of animals attract him and give him life
dreams give the nascopy complete ability
to find his way in life
not only in the inner world but also in
the outer world of nature
they help him to foretell the weather
and give him invaluable guidance in his
hunting
upon which his life depends i mention
these very primitive people because they
are uncontaminated by
our civilized ideas and still have
natural insight into the essence of what
jung calls
the self the self can be defined as an
inner guiding factor that is different
from the conscious personality
and that can be grasped only through the
investigation of one's own dreams
these show it to be the regulating
center that brings about a constant
extension
and maturing of the personality but this
larger
more nearly total aspect of the psyche
appears first as merely an inborn
possibility
it may emerge very slightly or it may
develop relatively completely during
one's lifetime
how far it develops depends on whether
or not the ego is willing to listen to
the messages of the self
just as the nascapi have noticed that a
person who is receptive to the hints of
the great man
gets better and more helpful dreams
we could add that the inborn great man
becomes more real within the receptive
person
than in those who neglect him such a
person also becomes a more complete
human being
it even seems as if the ego has not been
produced by nature to follow its own
arbitrary impulses to an unlimited
extent
but to help to make real the totality
the whole
psyche it is the ego that serves to
light up the entire system
allowing it to become conscious and thus
to be realized
if for example i have an artistic talent
of which my ego is not conscious
nothing will happen to it the gift may
as well be non-existent
only if my ego notices it can i bring it
into reality
the inborn but hidden totality of the
psyche is not the same thing
as a wholeness that is fully realized
and lived
one could picture this in the following
way the seed of a mountain pine contains
the whole future tree in a latent form
but each seed falls at a certain time
onto a particular place
in which there are a number of special
factors such as the quality of the soil
and the stones the slope of the land and
its exposure to sun and wind
the latent totality of the pine in the
seed
reacts to these circumstances by
avoiding the stones and inclining toward
the sun
with the result that the tree's growth
is shaped
thus an individual pine slowly comes
into existence
constituting the fulfillment of its
totality its emergence
into the realm of reality without the
living tree the image of the pine is
only a possibility or an abstract idea
again the realization of this uniqueness
in the individual man
is the goal of the process of
individuation
from one point of view this process
takes place in man
as well as in every other living being
by itself
and in the unconscious it is a process
by which man lives out his innate human
nature
strictly speaking however the process of
individuation
is real only if the individual is aware
of it and consequently makes a living
connection with it
we do not know whether the pine tree is
aware of its own growth
whether it enjoys and suffers the
different vicissitudes that shape it
but man certainly is able to participate
consciously in his development
he even feels that from time to time by
making free decisions
he can cooperate actively with it this
cooperation
belongs to the process of individuation
in the narrower sense of the word
man however experiences something that
is not contained in our metaphor of the
pine tree
the individuation process is more than a
coming to terms between the inborn germ
of wholeness
and the outer acts of fate its
subjective experience conveys the
feeling that some suprapersonal force
is actively interfering in a creative
way one sometimes feels that the
unconscious
is leading the way in accordance with a
secret design
it is as if something is looking at me
something that i do not
see but that sees me perhaps that great
man in the heart
who tells me his opinions about me by
means of dreams
but this creatively active aspect of the
psychic nucleus
can come into play only when the ego
gets rid of all
purposes and wishful aims and tries to
get to a deeper more basic form of
existence
the ego must be able to listen
attentively and to give itself
without any further design or purpose to
that inner urge toward growth
many existentialist philosophers try to
describe this state
but they go only as far as stripping off
the illusions of consciousness
they go right up to the door of the
unconscious and then
fail to open it people living in
cultures more securely rooted than our
own
have less trouble in understanding that
it is necessary to give up the
utilitarian attitude of conscious
planning
in order to make way for the inner
growth of the personality
i once met an elderly lady who had not
achieved much in her life
in terms of outward achievement but she
had in fact made a good marriage with a
difficult husband
and had somehow developed into a mature
personality
when she complained to me that she had
not done anything in her
life i told her a story related by a
chinese sage
juan zhu she understood immediately
and felt great relief this is the story
a wandering carpenter called stone saw
on his travels a gigantic old oak tree
standing in a field near an earth altar
the carpenter said to his apprentice who
was admiring the oak
this is a useless tree if you wanted to
make a ship
it would soon rot if you wanted to make
tools they would break
you can't do anything useful with this
tree and that's why it has become so old
but in an inn that same evening when the
carpenter went to sleep
the old oak tree appeared to him in his
dream and said
why do you compare me to your cultivated
trees such as white thorn
pear orange and apple trees and all the
others that bear fruit
even before they can ripen their fruit
people attack and violate them their
branches are broken their twigs are torn
their own gifts bring harm to them and
they cannot live out their natural span
that is what happens everywhere and that
is why i have long since tried to become
completely useless
you poor mortal imagine if i had been
useful in any way would i have reached
this size
furthermore you and i are both creatures
and how can one creature set himself so
high as to judge another creature
you useless mortal man what do you know
about useless trees
the carpenter woke up and meditated upon
his dream
and later when his apprentice asked him
why just this one tree
served to protect the earth altar he
answered
keep your mouth shut let's hear no more
about it
the tree grew here on purpose because
anywhere else people would have
ill-treated it
if it were not the tree of the earth
altar it might have been chopped down
the carpenter obviously understood his
dream he saw that simply to fulfill
one's destiny
is the greatest human achievement and
that our utilitarian notions have to
give way in the face of the demands of
our unconscious psyche
if we translate this metaphor into
psychological language
the tree symbolizes the process of
individuation
giving a lesson to our short-sighted ego
under the tree that fulfilled its
destiny there was
in juan zoo's story an earth altar
this was a crude unwrought stone upon
which people made sacrifices to the
local god who owned
this piece of land the symbol of the
earth altar points to the fact that in
order to bring the individuation process
into reality
one must surrender consciously to the
power of the unconscious
instead of thinking in terms of what one
should do
or of what is generally thought right or
of what usually happens
one must simply listen in order to learn
what the inner totality
the self wants one to do here and now in
a particular situation
note the local god to whom sacrifices
were made on the stone earth altar
corresponds in many respects to the
antique genius loci
paris 1955 page 140 and following
this information is owed to the kindness
of miss ariane rump
end of note our attitude must be like
that of the mountain pine mentioned
above
it does not get annoyed when its growth
is obstructed by a stone
nor does it make plans about how to
overcome the obstacles
it merely tries to feel whether it
should grow more toward the left or the
right
toward the slope or away from it like
the tree
we should give in to this almost
imperceptible yet powerfully dominating
impulse
an impulse that comes from the urge
toward unique creative self-realization
and this is a process in which one must
repeatedly seek out and find something
that is not yet known to anyone
the guiding hints or impulses come not
from the ego
but from the totality of the psyche the
self
it is moreover useless to cast furtive
glances at the way someone else is
developing
because each of us has a unique task of
self-realization
although many human problems are similar
they are never identical
all pine trees are very much alike
otherwise we should not recognize them
as pines
yet none is exactly the same as another
because of these factors of sameness and
difference
it is difficult to summarize the
infinite variations of the process of
individuation
the fact is that each person has to do
something different
something that is uniquely his own many
people have criticized the union
approach for not presenting psychic
material systematically
but these critics forget that the
material itself is a living experience
charged with emotion
by nature irrational and changing which
does not lend itself to systematization
except in the most superficial fashion
modern depth
psychology has here reached the same
limits that confront microphysics
that is when we are dealing with
statistical averages
a rational and systematic description of
the facts is possible
but when we are attempting to describe a
single psychic event
we can do no more than present an honest
picture of it
from as many angles as possible in the
same way
scientists have to admit that they do
not know what light is
they can say only that in certain
experimental conditions it seems to
consist of particles
while in other experimental conditions
it seems to consist of waves
but what it is in itself is not known
the psychology of the unconscious and
any description of the process of
individuation
encounter comparable difficulties of
definition
but i will try here to give a sketch of
some of their most typical features
the first approach of the unconscious
for most people the years of youth are
characterized by a state of gradual
awakening
in which the individual slowly becomes
aware of the world
and of himself childhood is a period of
great emotional intensity
and a child's earliest dreams often
manifest in symbolic form
the basic structure of the psyche
indicating how it will later shape the
destiny of the individual concerned
for example jung once told a group of
students about a young woman who was so
haunted by anxiety that she committed
suicide at the age of 26.
as a small child she had dreamed that
jack frost had entered her room while
she was lying in bed
and pinched her on the stomach she woke
and discovered that she had pinched
herself with her own hand
the dream did not frighten her she
merely remembered that she had had such
a dream
but the fact that she did not react
emotionally to her strange encounter
with the demon of the cold
of congealed life did not auger well for
the future
and was itself abnormal it was with a
cold unfeeling hand that she later put
an end to her life
from this single dream it is possible to
deduce the tragic fate of the dreamer
which was anticipated by her psyche in
childhood
sometimes it is not a dream but some
very
impressive and unforgettable real event
that like a prophecy
anticipates the future in symbolic form
it is well known that children often
forget events that seem
impressive to adults but keep a vivid
recollection of some incident or story
that no one else has noticed
when we look into one of these childhood
memories we usually find that it depicts
if interpreted as if it were a symbol a
basic problem of the child
psychic makeup when a child reaches
school age
the phase of building up the ego and of
adapting to the outer world begins
this phase generally brings a number of
painful shocks
at the same time some children begin to
feel very different from others
and this feeling of being unique brings
a certain sadness that is part of the
loneliness of many youngsters
the imperfections of the world and the
evil within oneself
as well as outside become conscious
problems
the child must try to cope with urgent
but not yet understood
inner impulses as well as the demands of
the outer world
if the development of consciousness is
disturbed in its normal unfolding
children frequently retire from outer or
inner difficulties
into an inner fortress and when that
happens their dreams and symbolic
drawings of unconscious material
often reveal to an unusual degree a type
of circular
quadrangular and nuclear motif which i
will explain later
this refers to the previously mentioned
psychic nucleus
the vital center of the personality from
which the whole structural development
of consciousness stems
it is natural that the image of the
center should appear in an especially
striking way
when the psychic life of the individual
is threatened
from this central nucleus as far as we
know today
the whole building up of ego
consciousness is directed
the ego apparently being a duplicate or
structural counterpart of the original
center
in this early phase there are many
children who earnestly seek for some
meaning in life
that could help them to deal with the
chaos both within
and outside themselves there are others
however
who are still unconsciously carried
along by the dynamism
of inherited and instinctive archetypal
patterns
these young people are not concerned
about the deeper meaning
of life because their experiences with
love nature
sport and work contain an immediate and
satisfying meaning for them
they are not necessarily more
superficial usually they are carried by
the stream of life with less friction
and disturbance than their more
introspective fellows
if i travel in a car or train without
looking out
it is only the stops starts and sudden
turns that make me realize i am moving
at all the actual process of
individuation
the conscious coming to terms with one's
own inner center
psychic nucleus or self generally begins
with a wounding of the personality
and the suffering that accompanies it
this initial shock amounts to a sort of
call although it is not often recognized
as such
on the contrary the ego feels hampered
in its will or its desire
and usually projects the obstruction
onto something external
that is the ego accuses god or the
economic situation
or the boss or the marriage partner of
being responsible for whatever is
obstructing it
or perhaps everything seems outwardly
all right but beneath the surface
a person is suffering from a deadly
boredom that makes everything seem
meaningless and empty
many myths and fairy tales symbolically
describe
this initial stage in the process of
individuation
by telling of a king who has fallen ill
or grown old
other familiar story patterns are that a
royal couple is barren
or that a monster steals all the women
children horses and wealth of the
kingdom
or that a demon keeps the king's army or
his ship from proceeding on its course
or that darkness hangs over the lands
wells dry up and
flood drought and frost afflict the
country
thus it seems as if the initial
encounter with the self
casts a dark shadow ahead of time or as
if the inner
friend comes at first like a trapper to
catch the helplessly struggling ego in
his snare
in myths one finds that the magic or
talisman that can cure the misfortune of
the king or his country
always proves to be something very
special
in one tale a white black bird or a fish
that carries a golden ring in its gills
is needed to restore the king's health
in another
the king wants the water of life or
three golden hairs from the head of the
devil
or a woman's golden plate and afterward
naturally the owner of the plate
whatever it is the thing that can drive
away the evil is always unique and hard
to find
it is exactly the same in the initial
crisis in the life of an individual
one is seeking something that is
impossible to find or about which
nothing is known
in such moments all well-meant sensible
advice is completely useless
advice that urges one to try to be
responsible to take a holiday
not to work so hard or to work harder to
have more or less human contact
or to take up a hobby none of that helps
or at best only rarely there is only one
thing that seems to work
and that is to turn directly toward the
approaching darkness
without prejudice and totally naively
and to try to find out what its secret
aim is
and what it wants from you the hidden
purpose of the oncoming darkness is
generally something so unusual
so unique and unexpected that as a rule
one can find out what it is only by
means of dreams and fantasies welling up
from the unconscious
if one focuses attention on the
unconscious without rash assumptions or
emotional rejection
it often breaks through in a flow of
helpful symbolic images
but not always sometimes it first offers
a series of painful realizations
of what is wrong with one's self and
one's conscious attitudes
then one must begin the process by
swallowing all sorts of bitter truths
the realization of the shadow
whether the unconscious comes up at
first in a helpful or a negative form
after a time the need usually arises to
re-adapt the conscious attitude in a
better way
to the unconscious factors therefore to
accept what seems to be criticism from
the unconscious
through dreams one becomes acquainted
with aspects of one's own personality
that for various reasons one is
preferred not to look at too closely
this is what jung called the realization
of the shadow
he used the term shadow for this
unconscious part of the personality
because it actually often appears in
dreams in a personified form
the shadow is not the whole of the
unconscious personality
it represents unknown or little-known
attributes and qualities of the ego
aspects that mostly belong to the
personal sphere and that could just as
well be conscious
in some aspects the shadow can also
consist of collective factors that stem
from a source outside the individual's
personal life
when an individual makes an attempt to
see his shadow
he becomes aware of and often ashamed of
those
qualities and impulses he denies in
himself but can plainly see in other
people
such things as egotism mental laziness
and sloppiness
unreal fantasies schemes and plots
carelessness and cowardice
inordinate love of money and possessions
in short
all the little sins about which he might
previously have told himself
that doesn't matter nobody will notice
it and in any case other people do it
too
if you feel an overwhelming rage coming
up in you when a friend reproaches you
about a fault
you can be fairly sure that at this
point you will find a part of your
shadow
of which you are unconscious it is of
course natural to become annoyed when
others who are no better
criticize you because of shadow faults
but what can you say if your
own dreams an inner judge in your own
being reproach you
that is the moment when the ego gets
caught and the result is usually
embarrassed
silence afterward the painful and
lengthy work of self-education begins
a work we might say that is the
psychological equivalent of the labors
of hercules
this unfortunate hero's first task you
will remember
was to clean up in one day the aegean
stables
in which hundreds of cattle had dropped
their dung for many decades
a task so enormous that the ordinary
mortal would be overcome by
discouragement at the mere thought of it
the shadow does not consist only of
omissions
it shows up just as often in an
impulsive or inadvertent act
before one has time to think the evil
remark pops out
the plot is hatched the wrong decision
is made and one is confronted with
results that were never intended or
consciously wanted
furthermore the shadow is exposed to
collective infections to a much greater
extent than is the conscious personality
when a man is alone for instance he
feels relatively alright
but as soon as the others do dark
primitive things
he begins to fear that if he doesn't
join in he will be considered a fool
thus he gives way to impulses that do
not really belong to him at all
it is particularly in contact with
people of the same
sex that one stumbles over both one's
own shadow
and those of other people although we do
see the shadow in a person of the
opposite sex
we are usually much less annoyed by it
and can more easily pardon it
in dreams and myths therefore the shadow
appears as a person of the same sex as
that of the dreamer
the following dream may serve as an
example the dreamer was a man of 48
who tried to live very much for and by
himself
working hard and disciplining himself
repressing pleasure and spontaneity to a
far greater extent than suited his real
nature
i owned and inhabited a very big house
in town
and i didn't yet know all its different
parts so i took a walk through it
and discovered mainly in the cellar
several rooms about which i knew nothing
and even exits leading into other
cellars or into subterranean streets
i felt uneasy when i found that several
of these exits were not
locked and some had no locks at all
moreover there were some laborers at
work in the neighborhood who could have
sneaked in
when i came up again to the ground floor
i passed a backyard where again i
discovered different exits into the
street or into
other houses when i tried to investigate
them more closely
a man came up to me laughing loudly and
calling out that we were old pals from
the elementary school
i remembered him too and while he was
telling me about his life
i walked along with him toward the exit
and strolled with him through the
streets
there was a strange chiaroscuro in the
air as we walked through an enormous
circular street
and arrived at a green lawn where three
galloping horses
suddenly passed us they were beautiful
strong animals
wild but well groomed and they had no
rider with them
had they run away from military service
the maze of strange passages chambers
and
unlocked exits in the cellar recalls the
old egyptian representation of the
underworld
which is a well-known symbol of the
unconscious with its unknown
possibilities
it also shows how one is open to other
influences in one's unconscious shadow
side
and how uncanny and alien elements can
break in
the cellar one can say is the basement
of the dreamer's psyche
in the backyard of the strange building
which represents the still unperceived
psychic scope of the dreamers
personality
an old school friend suddenly turns up
this person obviously personifies
another aspect of the dreamer himself
an aspect that had been part of his life
as a child but that he had forgotten and
lost
it often happens that a person's
childhood qualities for instance
gaiety irascibility or perhaps
trustfulness
suddenly disappear and one does not know
where or
how they have gone it is such a lost
characteristic of the dreamer that now
returns
from the backyard and tries to make
friends again
this figure probably stands for the
dreamer's neglected capacity for
enjoying life
and for his extroverted shadow side but
we soon learn
why the dreamer feels uneasy just before
meeting this seemingly harmless old
friend
when he strolls with him in the street
the horses break loose
the dreamer thinks they may have escaped
from military service that is to say
from the conscious discipline that has
hitherto characterized his life
the fact that the horses have no rider
shows that instinctive drives can get
away from conscious control
in this old friend and in the horses all
the positive force reappears that's
lacking before
and that was badly needed by the dreamer
this is a problem that often comes up
when one meets one's other side
the shadow usually contains values that
are needed by consciousness
but that exist in a form that makes it
difficult to integrate them into one's
life
the passages and the large house in this
dream
also show that the dreamer does not yet
know his own psychic dimensions
and is not yet able to fill them out the
shadow in this dream
is typical for an introvert a man who
tends to retire too much from outer life
in the case of an extrovert who is
turned more toward outer objects and
outer life
the shadow would look quite different a
young man who had a very lively
temperament
embarked again and again on successful
enterprises
while at the same time his dreams
insisted that he should finish off a
piece of private creative work he had
begun
the following was one of those dreams a
man is lying on a couch and has pulled
the cover over his face
he is a frenchman a desperado who would
take on any criminal job
an official is accompanying me
downstairs and i know
that a plot has been made against me
namely that the frenchman should kill me
as if by chance
that is how it would look from the
outside he actually sneaks up behind me
when we approach the exit
but i am on my guard a tall portly man
rather rich and influential suddenly
leans against the wall beside me
feeling ill i quickly grabbed the
opportunity to kill the official by
stabbing his heart
one only notices a bit of moisture this
is said like a comment
now i am safe for the frenchman won't
attack me since the man who gave him his
orders is dead
probably the official and the successful
portly man are the same person
the latter somehow replacing the former
the desperado represents the other side
of the dreamer
his introversion which has reached a
completely destitute
state he lies on a couch that is he is
passive
and pulls the cover over his face
because he wants to be left alone
the official on the other hand and the
prosperous portly man
who are secretly the same person
personify the dreamers successful outer
responsibilities and activities
the sudden illness of the portly man is
connected with the fact that this
dreamer had in fact become ill
several times when he allowed his
dynamic energy to explode too forcibly
in his external life
but this successful man has no blood in
his veins
only a sort of moisture which means that
these external ambitious activities of
the dreamer
contain no genuine life and no passion
but are bloodless mechanisms
thus it would be no real loss if the
portly man were killed
at the end of the dream the frenchman is
satisfied he obviously represents a
positive shadow figure who had turned
negative
and dangerous only because the conscious
attitude of the dreamer did not agree
with him
this dream shows us that the shadow can
consist of many different elements
for instance of unconscious ambition the
successful portly man and of
introversion
the frenchman this particular dreamers
association to the french
moreover was that they know how to
handle love affairs very well
therefore the two shadow figures also
represent two well-known drives
power and sex the power drive appears
momentarily in a double form
both as an official and as a successful
man
the official or a civil servant
personifies collective adaptation
whereas the successful man denotes
ambition
but naturally both serve the power drive
when the dreamer succeeds in stopping
this dangerous inner force
the frenchman is suddenly no longer
hostile in other words
the equally dangerous aspect of the sex
drive has also surrendered
obviously the problem of the shadow
plays a great role in all political
conflicts
if the man who had this dream had not
been sensible about his shadow problem
he could easily have identified the
desperate frenchman with the dangerous
communists of outer life
or the official plus the prosperous man
with the grasping capitalists
in this way he would have avoided seeing
that he had within
him such warring elements if people
observe their own unconscious tendencies
in other people
this is called a projection political
agitation in all countries is full of
such projections
just as much as the backyard gossip of
little groups and
individuals projections of all kinds
obscure our view of our fellow men
spoiling its objectivity and thus
spoiling all possibility of genuine
human relationships
and there is an additional disadvantage
in projecting our shadow
if we identify our own shadow with say
the communists or the capitalists
a part of our own personality remains on
the opposing side
the result is that we shall constantly
though involuntarily
do things behind our own backs that
support this other side
and thus we shall unwittingly help our
enemy
if on the contrary we realize the
projection and can discuss
matters without fear or hostility
dealing with the other person sensibly
then there is a chance of mutual
understanding or at least of a truce
whether the shadow becomes our friend or
enemy depends largely upon ourselves as
the dreams of the unexplored house
and the french desperado both show the
shadow is not necessarily
always an opponent in fact he is exactly
like any human being with whom one has
to get along
sometimes by giving in sometimes by
resisting
sometimes by giving love whatever the
situation requires
the shadow becomes hostile only when he
is ignored or misunderstood
sometimes though not often an individual
feels impelled to live
out the worst side of his nature and to
repress his better side
in such cases the shadow appears as a
positive figure in his dreams
but to a person who lives out his
natural emotions and feelings
the shadow may appear as a cold and
negative intellectual
it then personifies poisonous judgments
and negative thoughts that have been
held back
so whatever form it takes the function
of the shadow is to represent the
opposite side of the ego
and to embody just those qualities that
one dislikes most in other people
it would be relatively easy if one could
integrate the shadow into the conscious
personality
just by attempting to be honest and to
use one's insight
but unfortunately such an attempt does
not always work
there is such a passionate drive within
the shadowy part of oneself
that reason may not prevail against it a
bitter experience coming from the
outside may occasionally help
a brick so to speak has to drop on one's
head to put a stop to shadow drives and
impulses
at times a heroic decision may serve to
halt them
but such a superhuman effort is usually
possible only if the great man within
the self helps the individual to carry
it through
the fact that the shadow contains the
overwhelming power of irresistible
impulse
does not mean however that the drive
should always be heroically repressed
sometimes the shadow is powerful because
the urge of the self
is pointing in the same direction and so
one does not know whether it is the self
or the shadow that is behind the inner
pressure
in the unconscious one is unfortunately
in the same situation as in a moonlit
landscape
all the contents are blurred and merge
into one another
and one never knows exactly what or
where anything is
or where one thing begins and ends this
is known as the contamination
of unconscious contents when jung called
one aspect of the unconscious
personality the shadow
he was referring to a relatively well
defined factor
but sometimes everything that is unknown
to the ego
is mixed up with the shadow including
even the most valuable and highest
forces
who for instance could be quite sure
whether the french desperado and the
dream i quoted
was a useless [ __ ] or a most valuable
introvert
and the bolting horses of the preceding
dream
should they be allowed to run free or
not
in a case when the dream itself does not
make things clear
the conscious personality will have to
make the decision
if the shadow figure contains valuable
vital forces
they ought to be assimilated into actual
experience and not repressed
it is up to the ego to give up its pride
and friggishness
and to live out something that seems to
be dark but actually may not be
this can require a sacrifice just as
heroic as the conquest of passion
but in an opposite sense the ethical
difficulties that arise when one meets
one's shadow are well described in the
18th book of the quran
in this tale moses meets the green one
or first angel of god in the desert they
wander along together
and hitter expresses his fear that moses
will not be able to witness his deeds
without indignation
if moses cannot bear with him and trust
him hiber will have to leave
presently he that scuttles the fishing
boat of some poor villagers
then before moses's eyes he kills a
handsome young man
and finally he restores the fallen wall
of a city of unbelievers
moses cannot help expressing his
indignation and so hider has to leave
him
before his departure however he explains
the reasons for his actions
by scuttling the boat he actually saved
it for its owners because pirates were
on their way to steal it
as it is the fisherman can salvage it
the handsome young man was on his way to
commit a crime and by killing him he
that has saved his pious parents from
infamy
by restoring the wall two pious young
men were saved from ruin
because their treasure was buried under
it
moses who had been so morally indignant
saw now
too late that his judgment had been too
hasty
hither's doings had seemed to be totally
evil
but in fact they were not looking at
this story naively
one might assume that is the lawless
capricious evil shadow of pious law
abiding moses
but this is not the case hida is much
more the personification of some
secret creative actions of the godhead
one can find a similar meaning in the
famous indian story of the king and the
corpse
as interpreted by henry zimmer it is no
accident that i have not
quoted a dream to illustrate this subtle
problem
i have chosen this well-known story from
the quran
because it sums up the experience of a
lifetime which would very rarely be
expressed with such clarity
in an individual dream when dark figures
turn up in our dreams
and seem to want something we cannot be
sure whether they personify merely
a shadowy part of ourselves or the self
or both at the same time divining in
advance
whether our dark partner symbolizes a
shortcoming that we should overcome
or a meaningful bit of life that we
should accept
this is one of the most difficult
problems that we encounter on the way to
individuation
moreover the dream symbols are often so
subtle and complicated
that one cannot be sure of their
interpretation
in such a situation all one can do is
accept the discomfort of ethical doubt
making no final decisions or commitments
and continuing to watch the dreams
this resembles the situation of
cinderella when her stepmother threw a
heap of good and bad peas in front of
her
and asked her to sort them out although
it seemed quite hopeless
cinderella began patiently to sort the
peas
and suddenly doves or ants in some
versions came to help her
these creatures symbolize helpful deeply
unconscious impulses that can only be
felt in one's body as it were
and that point to a way out somewhere
right at the bottom of one's own being
one generally does
know where one should go and what one
should do
but there are times when the clown we
call i behaves in such a distracting
fashion
that the inner voice cannot make its
presence felt
sometimes all attempts to understand the
hints of the unconscious fail
and in such a difficulty one can only
have the courage to do what seems to be
right
while being ready to change course if
the suggestions of the unconscious
should suddenly point in another
direction it may also happen
although this is unusual that a person
will find it better to resist the urge
of the unconscious
even at the price of feeling warped by
doing so rather than depart too far
from the state of being human this would
be the situation of people who had to
live out a criminal disposition
in order to be completely themselves
the strength and inner clarity needed by
the ego
in order to make such a decision stem
secretly
from the great man who apparently does
not want to reveal himself
too clearly it may be that the self
wants the ego to make a free choice or
it may be that the self depends on human
consciousness
and its decisions to help him to become
manifest
when it comes to such difficult ethical
problems
no one can truly judge the deeds of
others
each man has to look to his own problem
and
try to determine what is right for
himself
as an old zen buddhist master said
we must follow the example of the
cowherd who watches his ox
with a stick so that it will not graze
on other people's meadows
these new discoveries of depth
psychology are bound to make some
change in our collective ethical views
for they will compel us to judge
all human actions in a much more
individual and subtle way
end of side five to continue
turn the cassette over side
six man and his symbols by carl g
young continuing with the process of
individuation on page 176
the discovery of the unconscious is one
of the most far-reaching discoveries of
recent times
but the fact that recognition of its
unconscious reality
involves honest self-examination and
reorganization of one's life
causes many people to continue to behave
as if nothing at all has happened
it takes a lot of courage to take the
unconscious seriously
and to tackle the problems it raises
most people are too indolent
to think deeply about even those moral
aspects of their behavior of which they
are conscious
they are certainly too lazy to consider
how the unconscious affects them
the anima the woman within
difficult and subtle ethical problems
are not invariably brought up by the
appearance of the shadow itself
often another inner figure emerges
if the dreamer is a man he will discover
a female personification of his
unconscious
and it will be a male figure in the case
of a woman
often this second symbolic figure turns
up behind the shadow
bringing up new and different problems
jung
called its male and female forms animus
and anima the anima is a personification
of all
feminine psychological tendencies in a
man's psyche
such as vague feelings and moods
prophetic hunches
receptiveness to the irrational capacity
for personal love
feeling for nature and last but not
least
his relation to the unconscious it is no
mere chance that in olden times
priestesses
like the greek sybil were used to fathom
the divine will
and to make connection with the gods a
particularly good example of how the
anima is experienced as an
inner figure in a man's psyche is found
in the medicine men
and prophets shamans among the eskimo
and other arctic tribes some of these
even wear women's clothes or have
breasts depicted on their garments
in order to manifest their inner
feminine side the side that enables them
to connect with the ghost land
that is what we call the unconscious
one reported case tells of a young man
who was being initiated by an older
shaman
and who was buried by him in a snow hole
he fell into a state of dreaminess and
exhaustion
in this coma he suddenly saw a woman who
emitted light
she instructed him in all he needed to
know and later as his protective spirit
helped him to practice his difficult
profession by relating him to the powers
of the beyond
such an experience shows the anima as
the personification of a man's
unconscious
in its individual manifestation the
character of a man's anima
is as a rule shaped by his mother if he
feels that his mother had a negative
influence on him
his animal will often express itself in
irritable depressed moods
uncertainty insecurity and touchiness
if however he is able to overcome the
negative assaults on himself
they can even serve to reinforce his
masculinity
within the soul of such a man the
negative mother anima figure will
endlessly repeat this theme
i am nothing nothing makes any sense
with others it's different but for me i
enjoy
nothing these anima moods cause a sort
of dullness
a fear of disease of impotence or of
accidents
the whole of life takes on a sad and
depressive aspect
such dark moods can even lure a man to
suicide in which case the anima becomes
a death demon
she appears in this role in cochteau's
film
or fae the french call such an anima
figure a fong fatale
a milder version of this dark anima is
personified by the queen of the night in
mozart's magic flute
the greek sirens or the german lorelei
also personify this dangerous aspect of
the anima
which in this form symbolizes
destructive illusion
the following siberian tale illustrates
the behavior of such a destructive anima
one day a lonely hunter sees a beautiful
woman emerging from the deep forest
on the other side of the river she waves
at him and sings
o come lonely hunter in the stillness of
dusk
come come i miss you i miss you
now i will embrace you embrace you come
come my nest is near my nest is near
come come lonely hunter now in the
stillness of dusk
he throws off his clothes and swims
across the river
but suddenly she flies away in the form
of an owl
laughing mockingly at him when he tries
to swim back to find his clothes
he drowns in the cold river
in this tale the anima symbolizes an
unreal dream of love
happiness and maternal warmth her nest
a dream that lures men away from reality
the hunter is drowned because he ran
after a wishful fantasy that could not
be fulfilled
another way in which the negative enemy
in a man's personality can be revealed
is in waspish poisonous effeminate
remarks by which he devalues everything
remarks of this sort always contain a
cheap twisting of the truth
and are in a subtle way destructive
there are legends throughout the world
in which a poisoned damsel
as they call her in the orient appears
she is a beautiful creature
who has weapons hidden in her body or a
secret poison with which she kills her
lovers during their first night together
in this guise the anima is as cold and
reckless
as certain uncanny aspects of nature
itself
and in europe is often expressed to this
day by the belief in witches
if on the other hand a man's experience
of his mother has been positive
this can also affect his anima in
typical but different ways
with the result that he either becomes
effeminate or is preyed upon
by women and thus is unable to cope with
the hardships of life
an anima of this sort can turn men into
sentimentalists
or they may become as touchy as old
maids or as sensitive
as the fairy tale princess who could
feel a pee under 30 mattresses
a still more subtle manifestation of a
negative anima
appears in some fairy tales in the form
of a princess who asks her suitors
to answer a series of riddles or perhaps
to hide themselves under her nose
if they cannot give the answers or if
she can find them
they must die and she invariably wins
the anima in this guys involves men in a
destructive intellectual game
we can notice the effect of this
animatric in all those neurotic
pseudo-intellectual dialogues that
inhibit a man from getting into direct
touch with life
and its real decisions he reflects about
life so much that he cannot live it
and loses all his spontaneity and
outgoing feeling
the most frequent manifestation of the
anima takes the form of erotic fantasy
men may be driven to nurse their
fantasies by looking at films and
striptease shows
or by daydreaming over pornographic
material
this is a crude primitive aspect of the
anima
which becomes compulsive only when a man
does not sufficiently cultivate his
feeling relationships
when his feeling attitude toward life
has remained infantile
all these aspects of the anima have the
same tendency that we have observed in
the shadow
that is they can be projected so that
they appear to the man to be the
qualities of some particular woman
it is the presence of the anima that
causes a man to fall
suddenly in love when he sees a woman
for the first time
and knows it once that this is she
in this situation the man feels as if he
has known this woman intimately for all
time
he falls for her so helplessly that it
looks to outsiders like complete madness
women who are a fairy-like character
especially attract such anima
projections
because men can attribute almost
anything to a creature who is so
fascinatingly vague
and can thus proceed to weave fantasies
around her
the projection of the anima in such a
sudden and passionate form as a love
affair
can greatly disturb a man's marriage and
can lead to the so-called human triangle
with its accompanying difficulties a
bearable solution to such a drama can be
found only if the anima is recognized as
an inner power
the secret aim of the unconscious in
bringing about such an entanglement
is to force a man to develop and to
bring his own
being to maturity by integrating more of
his unconscious personality
and bringing it into his real life but i
have said enough about the negative side
of the animal
there are just as many important
positive aspects
the anima is for instance responsible
for the fact that a man is able to find
the right marriage partner
another function is at least equally
important whenever a man's logical mind
is incapable of discerning facts that
are hidden in his unconscious
the anima helps him to dig them out even
more vital is the role that the anima
plays in putting a man's mind in tune
with the right inner values
and thereby opening the way into more
profound inner depths
it is as if an inner radio becomes tuned
to a certain wavelength that excludes
irrelevancies
but allows the voice of the great man to
be heard
in establishing this inner radio
reception the anima takes on the role of
guide or mediator
to the world within and to the self that
is how she appears in the example of the
initiations of shamans that i described
earlier
this is the role of beatrice in dante's
paradiso
and also of the goddess isis when she
appeared in a dream to opuleus
the famous author of the golden ass in
order to initiate him into a higher
more spiritual form of life the dream of
a 45 year old psychotherapist
may help to make clear how the anima can
be an inner guide
as he was going to bed on the evening
before he had this dream
he thought to himself that it was hard
to stand alone in life
lacking the support of a church he found
himself envying people who are protected
by the maternal embrace of an
organization
he had been born a protestant but no
longer had any religious affiliation
this was his dream i am in the isle of
an old church
filled with people together with my
mother and my wife
i sit at the end of the aisle in what
seemed to be extra seats
i am to celebrate the mass as a priest
and i have a big mass book in my hands
or rather a prayer book or an anthology
of poems
this book is not familiar to me and i
cannot find the right text
i am very excited because i have to
begin soon
and to add to my troubles my mother and
wife disturbed me by chattering about
unimportant trifles
now the organ stops and everybody is
waiting for me
so i get up in a determined way and ask
one of the nuns who is kneeling behind
me
to hand me her mass book and point out
the right place
which she does in an obliging manner now
like a sort of sexton this same nun
precedes me to the altar
which is somewhere behind me and to the
left as if we are approaching it from a
side aisle
the mask book is like a sheet of
pictures a sort of board
three feet long and a foot wide and on
it is
the text with ancient pictures in
columns one beside the other
first the nun has to read a part of the
liturgy before i begin
and i have still not found the right
place in the text
she has told me that it is number 15 but
the numbers are not clear
and i cannot find it with determination
however i turn toward the congregation
and now i have found number 15 the next
to the last on the board
although i do not yet know if i shall be
able to decipher it
i want to try all the same i wake up
this dream expressed in a symbolic way
an
answer from the unconscious to the
thoughts that the dreamer had had the
evening before
it said to him in effect you yourself
must become a priest in your own inner
church
in the church of your soul thus the
dream
shows that the dreamer does have the
helpful support of an organization
he is contained in a church not an
external church
but one that exists inside his own soul
the people all his own psychic qualities
want him to function as the priest
and celebrate the mass himself now the
dream cannot mean the actual mass
for its mass book is very different from
the real one
it seems that the idea of the mass is
used as a symbol
and therefore it means a sacrificial act
in which the divinity is present
so that man can communicate with it this
symbolic solution
is of course not generally valid but
relates to this particular dreamer
it is a typical solution for a
protestant because a man who through
real faith is still contained in the
catholic church
usually experiences his anima in the
image of the church herself
and her sacred images are for him the
symbols of the unconscious
our dreamer did not have this
ecclesiastical experience and this is
why he had to follow an inner way
furthermore the dream told him what he
should do it said
your mother boundness and your
extroversion represented by the wife who
is an extrovert
distract you and make you feel insecure
and by meaningless talk keep you from
celebrating the inner mass
but if you follow the nun the
introverted anima
she will lead you as both a servant and
a priest
she owns a strange mass book which is
composed of sixteen
four times four ancient pictures your
mass
consists of your contemplation of these
psychic images that your religious
animal reveals to you
in other words if the dreamer overcomes
his inner
uncertainty caused by his mother complex
he will find that his life task has the
nature and
quality of a religious service and that
if he meditates about the symbolic
meaning of the images in his soul
they will lead him to this realization
in this dream the anima appears in her
proper positive role
that is as a mediator between the ego
and the self
the four times four configuration of the
pictures points to the fact that the
celebration of this
inner mass is performed in the service
of totality
as jung has demonstrated the nucleus of
the psyche
the self normally expresses itself in
some kind of four-fold structure
the number four is also connected with
the anima because as jung noted
there are four stages in its development
the first stage is best symbolized by
the figure of eve
which represents purely instinctual and
biological relations
the second can be seen in faust's helen
she personifies a romantic and aesthetic
level
that is however still characterized by
sexual elements
the third is represented for instance by
the virgin mary
a figure who raises love arrows to the
heights of spiritual devotion
the fourth type is symbolized by
sapiencia
wisdom transcending even the most holy
and the most pure
of this another symbol is the shulamite
in the song of solomon
in the psychic development of modern man
this stage is rarely reached
the mona lisa comes nearest to such a
wisdom enema
at this stage i am only pointing out
that the concept of four-foldness
frequently occurs in certain types of
symbolic material
the essential aspects of this will be
discussed later
but what does the role of the anima as
guide to the inner world mean in
practical terms this positive function
occurs when a man takes seriously the
feelings
moods expectations and fantasies sent by
his anima
and when he fixes them in some form for
example
in writing painting sculpture musical
composition or dancing
when he works at this patiently and
slowly other
more deeply unconscious material wells
up from the depths and connects with the
earlier material
after a fantasy has been fixed in some
specific form
it must be examined both intellectually
and ethically
with an evaluating feeling reaction and
it is essential to regard it as being
absolutely real
there must be no lurking doubt that this
is only a fantasy
if this is practiced with devotion over
a long period
the process of individuation gradually
becomes the single reality
and can unfold in its true form
many examples from literature show the
anima as a guide
and mediator to the inner world
francesco colonos
hypno tamakia writer haggard she
or the eternal feminine in gerta's faust
in a medieval mystical text an anima
figure explains her own nature as
follows
i am the flower of the field and the
lily of the valleys
i am the mother of fair love and of fear
and of knowledge
and of holy hope i am the mediator of
the elements making one to agree with
another
that which is warm i make cold and the
reverse
and that which is dry i make moist and
the reverse
and that which is hard i soften i am the
law
in the priest and the word in the
prophet and the council in the wise
i will kill and i will make to live and
there is none that can deliver out of my
hand
in the middle ages there took place a
perceptible spiritual differentiation
in religious poetical and other cultural
matters
and the fantasy world of the unconscious
was recognized more clearly than before
during this period the knightly cult of
the lady signified an attempt to
differentiate the feminine side of man's
nature
in regard to the outer woman as well as
in relation to the inner world
the lady to whose service the knight
pledged himself and for whom he
performed his heroic deeds
was naturally a personification of the
anima
the name of the carrier of the grail
involved from eschenbach's version of
the legend
is especially significant come to your
mour
guide in love matters she taught the
hero to differentiate both
his feelings and his behavior toward
women
later however this individual and
personal effort of developing the
relationship with the anima was
abandoned when her sublime aspect fused
with the figure of the virgin
who then became the object of boundless
devotion and praise
when the anima as virgin was conceived
as being all positive
her negative aspects found expression in
the belief in witches
in china the figure parallel to that of
mary
is the goddess kuan yin a more popular
chinese anima figure is the lady of the
moon who bestows the gift of poetry or
music on her favorites
and can even give them immortality in
india the same archetype is represented
by shakti
parwati rati and many others among the
muslims
she is chiefly fatima the daughter of
muhammad
worship of the anima as an officially
recognized religious figure
brings the serious disadvantage that she
loses her individual aspects
on the other hand if she is regarded as
an exclusively personal being
there is the danger that if she is
projected into the outer world
it is only there that she can be found
this latter state of affairs can create
endless trouble
because man becomes either the victim of
his erotic fantasies
or compulsively dependent on one actual
woman
only the painful but essentially simple
decision to take one's fantasies and
feelings seriously
can at this stage prevent a complete
stagnation of the inner process of
individuation
because only in this way can a man
discover what this figure means as an
inner reality
thus the anima becomes again what she
originally was
the woman within who conveys the vital
messages of the self
the animus the man within
the male personification of the
unconscious in woman
the animus exhibits both good and bad
aspects
as does the anima in man but the animus
does not so often appear in the form of
an erotic fantasy or mood
it is more apt to take the form of a
hidden sacred conviction
when such a conviction is preached with
a loud insistent masculine voice
or imposed on others by means of brutal
emotional scenes
the underlying masculinity in a woman is
easily recognized
however even in a woman who is outwardly
very feminine
the animus can be an equally hard
inexorable power
one may suddenly find oneself up against
something in a woman that is obstinate
cold and completely inaccessible one of
the favorite themes that the animus
repeats endlessly in the ruminations of
this kind of woman
goes like this the only thing in the
world that i want is love
and he doesn't love me or in this
situation there are only two
possibilities and both are equally bad
the animus never believes in exceptions
one can rarely contradict an animus
opinion
because it is usually right in a general
way yet it seldom seems to fit the
individual situation
it is apt to be an opinion that seems
reasonable
but beside the point just as the
character of a man's anima
is shaped by his mother so the animus is
basically influenced by a woman's father
the father endows his daughter's animus
with the special coloring of unarguable
incontestably true convictions
convictions that never include the
personal reality of the woman herself as
she actually is
this is why the animus is sometimes like
the anima
a demon of death for example in a gypsy
fairy tale
a handsome stranger is received by a
lonely woman in spite of the fact that
she has had a dream warning her that he
is the king of the dead
after he has been with her for a time
she presses him to tell her who he
really is
at first he refuses saying that she will
die
if he tells her she insists however
and suddenly he reveals to her that he
is death himself
the woman immediately dies of fright
viewed mythologically the beautiful
stranger is probably a pagan father
image or god image who appears here as
king of the dead
like hades abduction of persephone but
psychologically
he represents a particular form of the
animus that lures women away from all
human relationships
and especially from all contacts with
real men
he personifies a cocoon of dreamy
thoughts filled with desire and
judgments about how things ought to be
which cut a woman off from the reality
of life
the negative animus does not appear only
as a death demon
in myths and fairy tales he plays the
role of robber and murderer
one example is bluebeard who secretly
kills all his wives in a hidden chamber
in this form the animus personifies all
those semi-conscious cold
destructive reflections that invade a
woman in the small hours
especially when she has failed to
realize some obligation of feeling
it is then that she begins to think
about the family heritage and
matters of that kind a sort of web of
calculating thoughts
filled with malice and intrigue which
get her into a state where she even
wishes
death to others when one of us dies i'll
move to the riviera said a woman to her
husband when she saw the beautiful
mediterranean coast
a thought that was rendered relatively
harmless by reason of the fact that she
said it
by nursing secret destructive attitudes
a wife can drive her husband
and a mother her children into illness
accident or even death
or she may decide to keep the children
from marrying
a deeply hidden form of evil that rarely
comes to the surface of the mother's
conscious mind
a naive old woman once said to me while
showing me a picture of her son
who was drowned when he was twenty seven
i prefer it this way
it's better than giving him away to
another woman
a strange passivity and paralysis of all
feeling
or a deep insecurity that can lead
almost to a sense of novelty
may sometimes be the result of an
unconscious animus opinion
in the depths of the woman's being the
animus whispers
you are hopeless what's the use of
trying there is no point in doing
anything
life will never change for the better
unfortunately whenever one of these
personifications of the unconscious
takes possession of our mind it seems as
if we ourselves are having such thoughts
and feelings
the ego identifies with them to the
point where it is unable to detach them
and see them for what they are
one is really possessed by the figure
from the unconscious
only after the possession has fallen
away does one realize with horror that
one has said and done
things diametrically opposed to one's
real thoughts and feelings
that one has been the prey of an alien
psychic factor
like the anima the animus does not
merely consist of negative qualities
such as brutality
recklessness empty talk and silent
obstinate evil ideas
he too has a very positive and valuable
side
he too can build a bridge to the self
through his creative activity
the following dream of a woman of 45 may
help to illustrate this point
two veiled figures climb onto the
balcony and into the house
they are swathed in black hooded coats
and they seem to want to torment me and
my sister
she hides under the bed but they pull
her out with a broom and torture her
then it is my turn the leader of the two
pushes me against the wall
making magical gestures before my face
in the meantime his helper makes a
sketch on the wall
and when i see it i say in order to seem
friendly
oh but this is well drawn now suddenly
my tormentor has the noble head of an
artist
and he says proudly yes indeed and
begins to clean his spectacles
the sadistic aspect of these two figures
was well known to the dreamer
for in reality she frequently suffered
bad attacks of anxiety during which she
was haunted by the thought that people
she loved were in great danger or even
that they were dead
but the fact that the animus figure in
the dream is double
suggests that the burglars personify a
psychic factor that is dual in its
effect
and that could be something quite
different from these tormenting thoughts
the sister of the dreamer who runs away
from the men is caught and tortured
in reality this sister died when fairly
young
she had been artistically gifted but it
made very little use of her talent
next the dream reveals that the veiled
burglars are actually disguised artists
and that if the dreamer recognizes their
gifts which are her own
they will give up their evil intentions
what is the deeper meaning of the dream
it is that behind the spasms of anxiety
there is indeed a genuine and mortal
danger but there is also a creative
possibility for the dreamer
she like the sister had some talent as a
painter but she doubted whether painting
could be a meaningful activity for her
now her dream tells her in the most
earnest way that she must live out this
talent
if she obeys the destructive tormenting
animus will be transformed into a
creative and meaningful activity
as in this dream the animus often
appears as a group of men
in this way the unconscious symbolizes
the fact that the animus represents a
collective rather than a personal
element
because of this collective mindedness
women habitually refer
when their animus is speaking through
them to one or they
or everybody and in such circumstances
their speech frequently contains the
words always and should
and ought a vast number of myths and
fairy tales
tell of a prince turned by witchcraft
into a wild animal or monster who is
redeemed by the love of a girl
a process symbolizing the manner in
which the animus becomes conscious
dr henderson has commented on the
significance of this beauty in the beast
motif in the preceding chapter
very often the heroine is not allowed to
ask questions about her mysterious
unknown lover and husband or she meets
him only in the dark
and may never look at him the
implication is that by blindly trusting
and loving him
she will be able to redeem her
bridegroom but this never succeeds
she always breaks her promise and
finally finds her lover again
only after a long difficult quest and
much suffering
the parallel in life is that the
conscious attention a woman has to give
to her animus problem
takes much time and involves a lot of
suffering
but if she realizes who and what her
animus is and what he does to her
and if she faces these realities instead
of allowing herself
to be possessed her animus can turn into
an invaluable inner companion
who endows her with the masculine
qualities of initiative
courage objectivity and spiritual wisdom
the animus just like the anima exhibits
four stages of development
he first appears as a personification of
mere physical power
for instance as an athletic champion or
muscle man
in the next stage he possesses
initiative and the capacity for planned
action
in the third phase the animus becomes
the word
often appearing as a professor or
clergyman
finally in his fourth manifestation the
animus is the incarnation of meaning
on this highest level he becomes like
the anima
a mediator of the religious experience
whereby life acquires new meaning
he gives the woman spiritual firmness an
invisible
inner support that compensates for her
outer softness
the animus in his most developed form
sometimes connects the woman's mind with
the spiritual evolution of her age
and can thereby make her even more
receptive than a man to new
creative ideas it is for this reason
that in earlier times
women were used by many nations as
diviners and seers
the creative boldness of their positive
animus at times expresses thoughts and
ideas that stimulate men to new
enterprises
the inner man within a woman's psyche
can lead to marital troubles
similar to those mentioned in the
section on the anima what makes things
especially complicated
is the fact that the possession of one
partner by the animus or anima
may automatically exert such an
irritating effect upon the other that he
or she becomes possessed too animus and
anima
always tend to drag conversation down to
a very low level
and to produce a disagreeable irratible
emotional atmosphere
as i mentioned before the positive side
of the animus can personify an
enterprising spirit
courage truthfulness and in the highest
form spiritual profundity
through him a woman can experience the
underlying processes of her cultural
and personal objective situation and can
find her way to an intensified spiritual
attitude to life
this naturally presupposes that her
animus ceases to represent opinions that
are above
criticism the woman must find the
courage and inner broad-mindedness
to question the sacredness of her own
convictions
only then will she be able to take in
the suggestions of the unconscious
especially when they contradict her
animus opinions
only then will the manifestations of the
self get through to her
and will she be able consciously to
understand their meaning
the self symbols of totality
if an individual has wrestled seriously
enough and long enough
with the anima or animus problem so that
he or she is no longer partially
identified with it
the unconscious again changes its
dominant character
and appears in a new symbolic form
representing the self
the innermost nucleus of the psyche in
the dreams of a woman
this center is usually personified as a
superior female figure
a priestess sorceress earth mother or
goddess
of nature or love in the case of a man
it manifests itself as a masculine
initiator and guardian
an indian guru a wise old man
a spirit of nature and so forth two folk
tales illustrate the role that such a
figure can play
the first is an austrian tale a king has
ordered soldiers to keep the night watch
beside the corpse of a black princess
who has been bewitched
every midnight she rises and kills the
guard
at last one soldier whose turn it is to
stand guard
despairs and runs away into the woods
there he meets an
old guitarist who is our lord himself
this old musician
tells him where to hide in the church
and instructs him on how to behave
so that the black princess cannot get
him with this divine help
the soldier actually manages to redeem
the princess and marry her
clearly the old guitarist who is our
lord himself is in psychological terms
a symbolic personification of the self
with his help
the ego avoids destruction and is able
to overcome and even redeem
a highly dangerous aspect of his animal
in a woman's psyche as i have said the
self assumes feminine personifications
this is illustrated in the second story
an eskimo tale
a lonely girl who has been disappointed
in love meets a wizard traveling in a
copper boat
he is the spirit of the moon who has
given all the animals to mankind
and who also bestows luck in hunting he
abducts the girl to the heavenly realm
once when the spirit of the moon has
left her she visits a little house near
the moon ghosts mansion
there she finds a tiny woman clothed in
the intestinal membrane of the bearded
seal
who warns the heroin against the spirit
of the moon saying that he plans to kill
her
it appears that he is a killer of women
a sort of blue beard
the tiny woman fashions a long rope by
means of which the girl can descend to
earth
at the time of the new moon which is the
moment when the little woman can weaken
the moon spirit
the girl climbs down but when she
arrives on earth
she does not open her eyes as quickly as
the little woman told her to
because of this she is turned into a
spider and can never become human again
as we have noted the divine musician in
the first tale is a representation of
the wise old man
a typical personification of the self he
is akin to the sorcerer merlin of
medieval legend
or to the greek god hermes the little
woman
in her strange membrane clothing is a
parallel figure
symbolizing the self as it appears in
the feminine psyche
the old musician saves the hero from the
destructive anima
and the little woman protects the girl
against the eskimo bluebeard
who is in the form of the moon spirit
her animus
in this case however things go wrong a
point that i shall take up later
the self however does not always take
the form of a wise old man or wise old
woman
these paradoxical personifications are
attempts to express something that is
not entirely contained in time
something simultaneously young and old
the dream of a middle-aged man shows the
self
appearing as a young man coming from the
street
a youth rode down into our garden there
were no bushes and no fence as there are
in real life
and the garden lay open i did not quite
know if he came on purpose or if the
horse carried him here against his will
i stood on the path that leads to my
studio and watched the arrival with
great pleasure
the sight of the boy on his beautiful
horse impressed me deeply
the horse was a small wild powerful
animal
a symbol of energy it resembled a boar
and it had a thick bristly silvery gray
coat
the boy rode past me between the studio
and house
jumped off his horse and led him
carefully away so that he would not
travel on the flower bed with its
beautiful red and orange tulips
the flower bed had been newly made and
planted by my wife
a dream occurrence this youth
signifies the self and with it renewal
of life
a creative elevator and a new spiritual
orientation by means of which everything
becomes full of life and enterprise
if a man devotes himself to the
instructions of his own unconscious
it can bestow this gift so that suddenly
life which has been stale and dull
turns into a rich unending inner
adventure full of creative possibilities
in a woman's psychology this same
youthful personification of the self can
appear as a supernaturally gifted girl
the dreamer in this instance is a woman
in her late forties
i stood in front of a church and was
washing the pavement with water
then i ran down the street just at the
moment when the students from the high
school were let out
i came to a stagnant river across which
a board or tree trunk had been laid
but when i was attempting to walk across
a mischievous student bounced on the
board so that it cracked
and i nearly fell into the water idiot i
yelled out
on the other side of the river three
little girls were playing and one of
them stretched out her hand as if to
help me
i thought that her small hand was not
strong enough to help me
but when i took it she succeeded without
the slightest effort
in pulling me across and up the bank on
the other side
the dreamer is a religious person but
according to her dream
she cannot remain in the church
protestant any longer
in fact she seems to have lost the
possibility of entering it
although she tries to keep the access to
it as clean as she can
according to the dream she must now
cross a stagnant river
and this indicates that the flow of life
is slowed down because of the unresolved
religious problem
crossing a river is a frequent symbolic
image for a fundamental change of
attitude
the student was interpreted by the
dreamer herself as the personification
of a thought that she had previously had
namely that she might satisfy her
spiritual yearning by attending high
school
obviously the dream does not think much
of this plan
when she dares to cross the river alone
a personification of the self
the girl small but supernaturally
powerful
helps her but the form of a human being
whether youthful or old is only one of
the many ways in which the self can
appear in dreams or visions
the various ages it assumes show not
only that it is with us throughout the
whole of life
but also that it exists beyond the
consciously realized flow of life
which is what creates our experience of
time
just as the self is not entirely
contained in our conscious experience of
time
in our space-time dimension it is also
simultaneously omnipresent
moreover it appears frequently in a form
that hints at a special omnipresence
that is it manifests itself as a
gigantic
symbolic human being who embraces and
contains the whole cosmos
when this image turns up in the dreams
of an individual we may hope for a
creative solution to his conflict
because now the vital psychic center is
activated
that is the whole being is condensed
into oneness
in order to overcome the difficulty it
is no wonder that this figure of the
cosmic man
appears in many myths and religious
teachings
generally he is described as something
helpful and positive
he appears as adam as the persian
gayomart
or as the hindu purusa this figure may
even be described as the basic principle
of the whole world
the ancient chinese for instance thought
that before anything whatever was
created
there was a colossal divine man called
panku
who gave heaven and earth their form
when he cried his tears made the yellow
river and the yang sea river
when he breathed the wind rose when he
spoke
thunder was loosed and when he looked
around lightning flashed
if he was in a good mood the weather was
fine if he was sad it clouded over
when he died he fell apart and from his
body the five holy mountains of china
sprang into existence
his head became the thai mountain in the
east his trunk
became the sun mountain in the center
his right arm the hung mountain in the
north
his left arm the hung mountain in the
south and his feet the wall mountain in
the west
his eyes became the sun and moon we have
already seen that symbolic structures
that seem to refer to the process of
individuation
tend to be based on the motif of the
number four such as the four functions
of consciousness or the four stages of
the anima or animus
it reappears here in the cosmic shape of
ponku
only under specific circumstances do
other combinations of numbers appear in
the psychic material
the natural unhampered manifestations of
the center
are characterized by four-foldness that
is to say by having four divisions
or some other structure deriving from
the numerical series of 4
8 16 and so on number 16 plays a
particularly important role
since it is composed of four fours
in our western civilization similar
ideas of a cosmic man
have attached themselves to the symbol
of adam the first man
there is a jewish legend that when god
created adam he first gathered red
black white and yellow dust from the
four corners of the world
and thus adam reached from one end of
the world to the other
when he bent down his head was in the
east and his feet in the west
according to another jewish tradition
the whole of mankind was contained in
adam from the beginning
which meant the soul of everybody who
would ever be born
the soul of adam therefore was like the
wick of a lamp composed of innumerable
strands
in this symbol the idea of a total
oneness of all human existence
beyond all individual units is clearly
expressed
in ancient persia the same original
first
man called gaiumart was depicted as a
huge figure emitting light
when he died every kind of metal sprang
from his body
and from his soul came gold his semen
fell upon the earth and from it came the
first human couple
in the form of two rhubarb shrubs it is
striking that the chinese poncu
was also depicted covered by leaves like
a plant
perhaps this is because the first man
was thought of as
a self-grown living unit that just
existed
without any animal impulse or self-will
among a group of people who live on the
banks of the tigris
adam is still at the present time
worshiped as the hidden super soul
or mystical protective spirit of the
entire human race
these people say that he came from a
date palm
another repetition of the plant motif
in the east and in some gnostic circles
in the west
people soon recognized that the cosmic
man was more an inner psychic image than
a concrete outer reality
according to hindu tradition for
instance he is something that lives
within the individual human
being and is the only part that is
immortal this inner great man
redeems the individual by leading him
out of creation
and its sufferings back into his
original eternal sphere
but he can do this only if man
recognizes him and rises from his sleep
in order to be led in the symbolic myths
of old india
this figure is known as the purusa a
name that simply means man or person
the purusha lives within the heart of
every individual
and yet at the same time he fills the
entire cosmos
according to the testimony of many myths
the cosmic man is not only the beginning
but also the final goal of all life
of the whole of creation all serial
nature
means wheat all treasure nature means
gold
all generation means man says the
medieval sage
meister eckhart and if one looks at this
from a psychological standpoint
it is certainly so the whole inner
psychic reality of each individual
is ultimately oriented toward this
archetypal symbol of the self
in practical terms this means that the
existence of human beings
will never be satisfactorily explained
in terms of isolated instincts or
purposive mechanisms such as hunger
power sex survival perpetuation of the
species and so on
that is man's main purpose is not to eat
drink
etc but to be human above and beyond
these drives
our inner psychic reality serves to
manifest a living mystery that can be
expressed only by a symbol
and for its expression the unconscious
often chooses the powerful image of the
cosmic man
in our western civilization the cosmic
man has been identified to a great
extent with christ
and in the east with krsna or with
buddha in the old testament
this same symbolic figure turns up as
the son of man
and in later jewish mysticism is called
adam kadmon
certain religious movements of late
antiquity simply called him anthropos
the greek word for man like all symbols
this image points to an unknowable
secret to the ultimate
unknown meaning of human existence as we
have noted
certain traditions assert that the
cosmic man is the goal of creation
but the achievement of this should not
be understood as a possible external
happening
from the point of view of the hindu for
example it is not so much
that the external world will one day
dissolve into the original great man
but that the ego's extroverted
orientation toward the external world
will disappear
in order to make way for the cosmic man
this happens when the ego
merges into the self the ego's
discursive flow of representations which
goes from one thought to another
and its desires which run from one
object to another
calm down when the great man within is
encountered
indeed we must never forget that for us
outer reality exists only in so far as
we perceive it consciously
and that we cannot prove that it exists
in and by itself
the many examples coming from various
civilizations
and different periods show the
universality of the symbol of the great
man
his image is present in the minds of men
as a sort of
goal or expression of the basic mystery
of our life
because this symbol represents that
which is whole and complete
it is often conceived of as a bisexual
being
in this form the symbol reconciles one
of the most important pairs of
psychological opposites
male and female this union also appears
frequently in dreams as a divine
royal or otherwise distinguished couple
the following dream
of a man of 47 shows this aspect of the
self
in a dramatic way i am on a platform
and below me i see a huge black
beautiful she-bear with a rough but
well-groomed coat
she is standing on her hind legs and on
a stone
slab she is polishing a flat oval black
stone
which becomes increasingly shiny not far
away
a lioness and her cub do the same thing
but the stones they are polishing are
bigger and round in shape
after a while the she-bear turns into a
fat naked woman with black hair and
dark fiery eyes i behave in a
neurotically provocative way toward her
and suddenly she moves nearer in order
to catch me
i get frightened and take refuge upon
the building of scaffolding where i was
before
later i am in the midst of many women
half of whom are primitive and have rich
black hair
as if they are transformed from animals
the other half are our women
of the same nationality as the dreamer
and have blonde or brown hair
the primitive women sing a very
sentimental song in melancholy high
pitched voices
now in a high elegant carriage there
comes a young man who wears on his head
a royal golden crown
set with shining rubies a very beautiful
sight
beside him sits a blonde young woman
probably his wife
but without a crown it seems that the
lioness and her cub have been
transformed into this couple
they belong to the group of primitives
now all the women
the primitives and the others in tone a
solemn song
and the royal carriage slowly travels
toward the horizon
here the inner nucleus of the dreamer's
psyche shows itself at first
in a temporary vision of the royal
couple which emerges from the depths of
his animal nature
and the primitive layer of his
unconscious the she-bear in the
beginning is a sort of mother goddess
artemis for instance was worshiped in
greece as a she-bear
the dark oval stone that she rubs and
polishes
probably symbolizes the dreamers
innermost being
his true personality rubbing and
polishing
stones is a well-known exceedingly
ancient activity of man
in europe holy stones wrapped in bark
and hidden in caves
have been found in many places as
containers of divine powers they were
probably kept
there by men of the stone age at the
present time
some of the australian aborigines
believe that their dead ancestors
continue to exist in stones as virtuous
and divine powers
and that if they rub these stones the
power increases
like charging them with electricity for
the benefit of both the living and the
dead
the man who had the dream we are
discussing had hitherto refused to
accept a marital bond with a woman
his fear of being caught by this aspect
of life
caused him in the dream to flee from the
bear woman to the spectator's platform
where he could passively watch things
without becoming entangled
through the motif of the stone being
rubbed by the bear the unconscious is
trying to show him that he should let
himself come into contact with this side
of life
it is through the frictions of married
life that his inner being can be shaped
and polished
when the stone is polished it will begin
to shine like a mirror so that the bear
can see herself in it
this means that only by accepting
earthly contact and suffering
can the human soul be transformed into a
mirror in which the divine powers can
perceive themselves
but the dreamer runs away to a higher
place that is
into all sorts of reflections by which
he can escape the demands of life
the dream then shows him that if he runs
away from the demands of life
one part of his soul his anima will
remain undifferentiated
a fact symbolized by the group of
nondescript women that splits apart into
a primitive half and a more civilized
one
the lioness and her son which then
appear on the scene
personify the mysterious urge toward
individuation indicated by their work at
shaping the round stones
a round stone is a symbol of the self
the lions a royal couple
are in themselves a symbol of totality
in medieval symbolism
the philosopher's stone a preeminent
symbol of man's wholeness
is represented as a pair of lions or as
a human couple
riding on lions symbolically this points
to the fact that often the urge toward
individuation
appears in a veiled form hidden in the
overwhelming passion one may feel for
another person
in fact passion that goes beyond the
natural measure of love
ultimately aims at the mystery of
becoming whole and this is why one feels
when one has fallen passionately in love
that becoming one with the other person
is the only worthwhile goal of one's
life
as long as the image of totality in this
dream expresses itself in the form of a
pair of lions
it is still contained in some such
overwhelming passion
but when lion and lioness have turned
into a king and queen
the urge to individuate has reached the
level of conscious realization
and can now be understood by the ego as
being the real goal of life
before the lions had transformed
themselves into human beings
it was only the primitive women who sang
and they did so in a sentimental manner
that is to say the feelings of the
dreamer remained on a primitive and
sentimental level
but in honor of the humanized lions both
the primitive
and the civilized women chant a common
hymn of praise
their expression of their feelings in a
united form
shows that the inner split in the animal
has now changed into inner harmony
still another personification of the
self appears in a report of a woman's
so-called active imagination
active imagination is a certain way of
meditating imaginatively
by which one may deliberately enter into
contact with the unconscious
and make a conscious connection with
psychic phenomena
active imagination is among the most
important of jung's discoveries
while it is in a sense comparable to
eastern forms of meditation such as the
technique of zen buddhism
or of tantric yoga or to western
techniques like those of the jesuit
exercise
it is fundamentally different in that
the meditator remains completely devoid
of any conscious goal or program
thus the meditation becomes the solitary
experiment of a free individual
which is the reverse of a guided attempt
to master the
unconscious this however is not the
place to enter into a detailed analysis
of active imagination
the reader will find one of jung's
descriptions of it in his paper on the
transcendent function
in the woman's meditation the self
appeared as a deer
which said to the ego i am your child
and your mother
they call me the connecting animal
because i connect people
animals and even stones with one another
if i enter them
i am your fate or the objective i
when i appear i redeem you from the
meaningless hazards of life
the fire burning inside me burns in the
hole of nature
if a man loses it he becomes egocentric
lonely
disoriented and weak the self is often
symbolized as an animal
representing our instinctive nature and
its connectedness with one's
surroundings
that is why there are so many helpful
animals in myths and fairy tales
this relation of the self to all
surrounding nature and even the cosmos
probably comes from the fact that the
nuclear atom of our psyche is somehow
woven into the whole world
both outer and inner all the higher
manifestations of life are somehow
tuned to the surrounding space-time
continuum
animals for example have their own
special foods
their particular home building materials
and their definite territories
to all of which their instinctive
patterns are exactly tuned and adapted
time rhythms also play their part we
have only to think of the fact that most
grass-eating animals have their young at
precisely the time of year when the
grass is richest
and most abundant with such
considerations in mind
a well-known zoologist has said that the
inwardness of each animal reaches far
out into the world around it and
sacrifice time and space
in ways that are so completely beyond
our comprehension
our unconscious is similarly attuned to
our surroundings
to our group to society in general and
beyond these to the space-time continuum
and the whole of nature thus the great
man of the nazca
indians does not merely reveal inner
truths
he also gives hints about where and when
to hunt
and so from dreams the nascapie hunter
evolves the words and melodies of the
magical songs with which he attracts the
animals
but this specific help from the
unconscious is not given to primitive
man alone
jung discovered that dreams can also
give civilized man the guidance he needs
in finding his way through the problems
of both his inner and his outer life
indeed many of our dreams are concerned
with details of our outer life and our
surroundings
such things as the tree in front of the
window one's bicycle or car
or a stone picked up during a walk may
be raised to the level of symbolism
through our dream life
and become meaningful if we pay
attention to our dreams instead of
living in a cold
impersonal world of meaningless chance
we may begin to emerge into a world of
our own
full of important and secretly ordered
events
our dreams however are not as a rule
primarily concerned with our adaptation
to outer life
in our civilized world most dreams have
to do with the development by the ego
of the right inner attitude toward the
self for this relationship is far more
disturbed in us
by modern ways of thinking and behaving
than is the case with primitive people
they generally live directly from the
inner center but we
with our uprooted consciousness are so
entangled with external completely
foreign matters
that it is very difficult for the
messages of the self to get through to
us
our conscious mind continually creates
the illusion of a clearly shaped
real outer world that blocks off many
other perceptions
yet through our unconscious nature we
are inexplicably connected to our
psychic and physical environment
i have already mentioned the fact that
the self is symbolized with special
frequency in the form of a stone
precious or otherwise
we saw an example of this in the stone
that was being polished by the she-bear
and the lions
in many dreams the nuclear center the
self also appears as a crystal
the mathematically precise arrangement
of a crystal evokes in us the intuitive
feeling that even in so-called
dead matter there is a spiritual
ordering principle at work
thus the crystal often symbolically
stands for the union of extreme
opposites
of matter and spirit perhaps
crystals and stones are especially apt
symbols of the self because of the just
sonus of their nature
many people cannot refrain from picking
up stones of a slightly unusual color or
shape and keeping them
without knowing why they do this it is
as if the stones held a living mystery
that fascinates them
men have collected stones since the
beginning of time and have apparently
assumed that certain ones were the
containers of the life force
with all its mystery the ancient germans
for instance believed that the spirits
of the dead continued to live in their
tombstones
the custom of placing stones on graves
may spring partly from the symbolic idea
that something eternal of the dead
person remains
which can be most fittingly represented
by a stone
for while the human being is as
different as possible from a stone
yet man's innermost center is in a
strange and special way akin to it
perhaps because the stone symbolizes
mere existence at the farthest removed
from the emotions
feelings fantasies and discursive
thinking of ego consciousness
in this sense the stone symbolizes what
is perhaps the simplest and deepest
experience
the experience of something eternal that
man can have in those moments when he
feels immortal and
unalterable the urge that we find in
practically all civilizations to erect
stone monuments to famous men
or on the site of important events
probably also stems from the symbolic
meaning of the stone
the stone that jacob placed on the spot
where he had his famous dream
or certain stones left by simple people
on the tombs of local saints or heroes
show the original nature of the human
urge to express an otherwise
inexpressible experience by the stone
symbol
it is no wonder that many religious
cults use a stone
to signify god or to mark a place of
worship
the holiest sanctuary of the islamic
world is the kaaba
the black stone in mecca to which all
pious muslims hope to make their
pilgrimage
according to christian ecclesiastical
symbolism christ is the stone which the
builders rejected
which became the head of the corner luke
20
17 alternatively he is called the
spiritual rock from which the water of
life springs
first corinthians 10 4
medieval alchemists who searched for the
secret of matter in a pre-scientific way
hoping to find god in it or at least the
working of divine activity
believed that this secret was embodied
in their famous philosopher's stone
but some of the alchemists dimly
perceived that their much sought after
stone was a symbol of something that can
be found only within the psyche of man
an old arabian alchemist morianis said
this thing the philosopher's stone is
extracted from you
you are its mineral and one can find it
in you or to put it more clearly
they the alchemists take it from you if
you recognize this
the love and affirmation of the stone
will grow within you
know that this is true without doubt
the alchemical stone the lapis
symbolizes something that can never be
lost or dissolved
something eternal that some alchemists
compared to the mystical experience of
god within one's own soul
it usually takes prolonged suffering to
burn away all the superfluous psychic
elements concealing the stone
but some profound inner experience of
the self does occur to most people at
least once in a lifetime
from the psychological standpoint a
genuinely religious attitude consists of
an effort to discover this unique
experience
and gradually to keep in tune with it it
is relevant that a stone is itself
something permanent
so that the self becomes an inner
partner toward whom one's attention is
continually turned
the fact that this highest and most
frequent symbol of the self
is an object of lifeless matter points
to yet another field of inquiry and
speculation
that is the still unknown relationship
between what we call the unconscious
psyche
and what we call matter a mystery with
which psychosomatic medicine
endeavors to grapple in studying this
still undefined and
unexplained connection it may prove to
be that psyche and matter are actually
the same phenomenon
one observed from within and the other
from without
dr young put forward a new concept that
he called synchronicity
this term means a meaningful coincidence
of outer and inner events that are not
themselves causally connected
the emphasis lies on the word meaningful
if an aircraft crashes before my eyes as
i am blowing my nose
this is a coincidence of events that has
no meaning
it is simply a chance occurrence of a
kind that happens all the time
but if i bought a blue frock and by
mistake the shop delivered a black one
on the day one of my new relatives died
this would be a meaningful coincidence
the two events are not causally related
but they are connected by the symbolic
meaning that our society gives to the
color black
wherever dr young observed such more
coincidences in an individual's life
it seemed as the individual's dreams
revealed
that there was an archetype activated in
the uncut of the individual concerned
to illustrate this by my example of the
black frock
in such a case the person who receives
the black frock might also have had a
dream
on the theme of death it seems as if the
underlying archetype is manifesting
itself simultaneously in inner and
external events
the common denominator is a symbolically
expressed message
in this case a message about death
as soon as we notice that certain types
of event
like to cluster together at certain
times we begin to understand the
attitude of the chinese
whose theories of medicine philosophy
and even building are based on a science
of meaningful coincidences
the classical chinese texts did not ask
what causes what
but rather what likes to occur with what
one can see much the same underlying
theme in astrology
and in the way various civilizations
have depended on consulting oracles and
paying attention to omens
all of these are attempts to provide an
explanation of coincidence that is
different from one that depends on
straightforward cause and effect
in creating the concept of synchronicity
dr young sketched a way in which we
might penetrate deeper into the
interrelation of psyche and matter
and it is precisely tore in such a
relation that the symbol of the stone
seems to point but this is still a
completely open and insufficiently
explored matter
with which future generations of
psychologists and physicists must deal
it may seem that my discussion of
synchronicity has led me away from my
main theme
but i feel it is necessary to make at
least a brief introductory reference to
it
because it is a jungian hypothesis that
seems to be pregnant with future
possibilities of investigation and
application
synchronistic events moreover almost
invariably accompany the crucial phases
of the process of individuation
but too often they pass unnoticed
because the individual has not learned
to watch for such coincidences
and to make them meaningful in relation
to the symbolism of his dreams
the relation to the self nowadays
more and more people especially those
who live in large cities
suffer from a terrible emptiness and
boredom as if they were waiting for
something that never arrives
movies and television spectator sports
and political excitements
may divert them for a while but again
and again exhausted and disenchanted
they have to return to the wasteland of
their own lives
the only adventure that is still
worthwhile for modern man
lies in the inner realm of the
unconscious psyche
with this idea vaguely in mind many now
turn to yoga and other eastern practices
but these offer no genuine new adventure
for in them one only takes over what is
already known to the hindus or the
chinese
without directly meeting one's own inner
life center
while it is true that eastern methods
serve to concentrate the mind and direct
it inward
and that this procedure is in a sense
similar to the introversion of an
analytical treatment
there is a very important difference
jung evolved a way of getting to one's
inner center
and making contact with the living
mystery of the unconscious
alone and unaided that is utterly
different from
following a well-worn path trying to
give the living reality of the self a
constant amount of daily attention
is like trying to live simultaneously on
two levels or in two different worlds
one gives one's mind as before to outer
duties
but at the same time one remains alert
for hints and signs
both in dreams and in external events
that the self
uses to symbolize its intentions the
direction in which the life stream is
moving
old chinese texts that are concerned
with this kind of experience
often use the simile of the cat watching
the mouse hole
one text says that one should allow no
other thoughts to intrude
but one's attention should not be too
sharp nor should it be too dull
there is exactly the right level of
perception
if the training is undergone in this
manner it will be effective as time goes
on
and when the cause comes to fruition
like a ripe melon that automatically
falls
anything it may happen to touch or make
contact with
will suddenly cause the individual's
awakening
this is the moment when the practitioner
will be like one who drinks water and
alone
knows whether it is cold or warm he
becomes about himself
and experiences a great happiness
similar to that one feels in meeting
one's own father at the crossroads
thus in the midst of ordinary outer life
one is suddenly caught up in an exciting
inner adventure and because it is unique
for each individual
it cannot be copied or stolen there are
two main reasons why man loses contact
with the regulating center of his soul
one of them is that some single
instinctive drive or emotional image
can carry him into a one-sidedness that
makes him lose his balance
this also happens to animals for example
a sexually excited stag
will completely forget hunger and
security
this one-sidedness and consequent loss
of balance are much dreaded by
primitives
who call it loss of soul another threat
to the inner balance comes from
excessive daydreaming which in a secret
way usually circles around particular
complexes
in fact daydreams arise just because
they connect a man with his complexes
at the same time they threaten the
concentration and continuity of his
consciousness
the second obstacle is exactly the
opposite and is due to an over
consolidation of ego consciousness
although a disciplined consciousness is
necessary for the performance of
civilized activities
we know what happens if a railway
signalman lapses into daydreaming
it has the serious disadvantage that it
is apt to block the reception of
impulses and messages coming from the
center
this is why so many dreams of civilized
people are concerned with restoring
this receptivity by attempting to
correct the attitude of consciousness
toward the unconscious center or self
among the mythological representations
of the self
one finds much emphasis on the four
corners of the world
and in many pictures the great man is
represented in the center of a circle
divided into four
jung used the hindu word mandala magic
circle
to designate a structure of this order
which is a symbolic representation of
the nuclear atom of the human psyche
whose essence we do not know in this
connection it is interesting that a
nascapie hunter pictorially represented
his great man not as a human being but
as a mandala
whereas the nascope experienced the
inner center directly and naively
without the help of religious rights or
doctrines
other communities use the mandala motif
in order to restore a lost inner balance
for instance the navajo indians try by
means of mandala structured sand
paintings
to bring a sick person back into harmony
with himself and with the cosmos
and thereby to restore his health in
eastern civilizations
similar pictures are used to consolidate
the inner being
or to enable one to plunge into deep
meditation
the contemplation of a mandala is meant
to bring an inner peace
a feeling that life has again found its
meaning and order
the mandala also conveys this feeling
when it appears spontaneously in the
dreams of modern men who are not
influenced by any religious
tradition of this sort and know nothing
about it
perhaps the positive effect is even
greater in such cases
because knowledge and tradition
sometimes blur or even block the
spontaneous experience
an example of the spontaneously produced
mandala occurs in the following dream of
a 62 year old woman
it emerged as a prelude to a new phase
of life in which she became very
creative
i see a landscape in a dim light in the
background
i see the rising and then evenly
continuing crest of a hill
along the line where it rises moves a
quadrangular disk that shines like gold
in the foreground i see dark plowed
earth that is beginning to sprout
now i suddenly perceive a round table
with a gray stone slab as its top
and at the same moment the quadrangular
disk suddenly stands upon the table
it has left the hill but how and why it
has changed its place i do not know
landscapes in dreams as well as in art
frequently symbolize an inexpressible
mood
in this dream the dim light of the
landscape indicates that the clarity of
daytime consciousness is dimmed
inner nature may now begin to reveal
itself in its own light
so we are told that the quadrangular
disk becomes visible on the horizon
hitherto the symbol of the self the disc
had been largely an intuitive idea on
the dreamer's mental horizon
but now in the dream it shifts its
position and becomes the center of the
landscape of her soul
a seed sown long ago begins to sprout
for a long time previously the dreamer
had paid careful attention to her dreams
and now this work bears fruit one is
reminded of the relation between the
symbol of the great man and
plant life which i mentioned before
now the golden disk suddenly moves to
the right side
the side where things become conscious
among other things
right often means psychologically the
side of consciousness
of adaptation of being right while left
signifies the sphere of unadapted
unconscious reactions or sometimes even
of something sinister
then finally the golden disc stops its
movement
and comes to rest on significantly
around stone
table it has found a permanent base
as anyella jaffe observes later in this
book
roundness the mandala motif generally
symbolizes a natural wholeness
whereas a quadrangular formation
represents the realization of this
in consciousness in the dream the square
disk and the round table meet
and thus a conscious realization of the
center is at hand
the round table incidentally is a
well-known symbol of wholeness and plays
a role in mythology
for instance king arthur's round table
which itself is an image derived from
the table of the last
supper in fact whenever a human being
genuinely turns to the inner world and
tries to know himself
not by ruminating about his subjective
thoughts and feelings
but by following the expressions of his
own objective nature
such as dreams and genuine fantasies
then
sooner or later the self emerges the ego
will then find an inner power that
contains all the possibilities of
renewal
but there is a great difficulty that i
have mentioned only indirectly up till
now
this is that every personification of
the unconscious
the shadow the anima the animus and the
self
has both a light and a dark aspect
we saw before that the shadow may be
base or evil
an instinctive drive that one ought to
overcome
it may however be an impulse toward
growth that one should cultivate and
follow
in the same way the anima and animus
have dual aspects
they can bring life-giving development
and creativeness to the personality
or they can cause petrification and
physical death
and even the self the all-embracing
symbol of the unconscious
has an ambivalent effect as for instance
in the eskimo tale
when the little woman offered to save
the heroine from the moon spirit
but actually turned her into a spider
the dark side of the self is the most
dangerous thing of all
precisely because the self is the
greatest power in the psyche
it can cause people to spin megalomaniac
or other delusionary fantasies that
catch them up and possess them
a person in this state thinks with
mounting excitement that he has grasped
and solved the great cosmic riddles
he therefore loses all touch with human
reality
a reliable symptom of this condition is
the loss of one's sense of humor and of
human contacts
thus the emerging of the self may bring
great danger to a man's conscious ego
the double aspect of the self is
beautifully illustrated by this old
iranian fairy tale
called the secret of the bath bod good
the great and noble prince hatim thai
receives orders from his king
to investigate the mysterious
prothbodgard
castle of non-existence when he
approaches it having gone through many
dangerous adventures
he hears that nobody ever returned from
it but he insists on going on
he is received at a round building by a
barber with a mirror who leads him into
the bath
but as soon as the prince enters the
water a thunderous noise breaks out
it gets completely dark the barber
disappears
and slowly the water begins to rise
swims desperately round until the water
finally reaches the top of the round
cupola
which forms the roof of the bath now he
fears he is lost
but he says a prayer and grabs the
center stone of the cupola
again a thunderous noise everything
changes
and hatin stands alone in a desert
after a long and painful wandering he
comes to a beautiful garden
in the middle of which is a circle of
stone statues
in the center of the statues he sees a
parrot in its cage
and the voice from above says to him oh
hero
you probably will not escape alive from
this bath
once gaiumart the first man found an
enormous diamond that shone more
brightly than sun and moon
he decided to hide it where no one can
find it and therefore he built this
magical bath in order to protect it
the parrot that you see here forms part
of the magic
at its feet lie a golden bow and arrow
on a golden chain
and with them you may try three times to
shoot the parrot
if you hit him the curse will be lifted
if not you will be petrified
as were all these other people ha team
tries once and fails
his legs turn to stone he fails once
more
and is petrified up to his chest the
third time he just
shuts his eyes exclaiming god is great
shoots blindly and this time hits the
parrot
an outbreak of thunder clouds of dust
when all this has subsided
in place of the parrot is an enormous
beautiful diamond
and all the statues have come to life
again the people thank him for their
redemption
the reader will recognize the symbols of
the self in this story
the first man the round mandala shaped
building
the center stone and the diamond but
this diamond is surrounded by danger
the demonic parrot signifies the evil
spirit of imitation that makes one miss
the target
and petrifies psychologically as i
pointed out earlier
the process of individuation excludes
any parrot-like imitation of others
time and again in all countries people
have tried to copy in outer or
ritualistic behavior
the original religious experience of
their great religious teachers
christ or buddha or some other master
and have therefore become petrified
to follow in the steps of a great
spiritual leader does not mean that one
should copy
and act out the pattern of the
individuation process made by his life
it means that we should try with a
sincerity and devotion
equal to his to live our own lives
the barber with the mirror who vanishes
symbolizes the gift of reflection that
hatin loses when he wants it most
the rising waters represent the risk
that one may drown in the unconscious
and get lost in one's own emotions in
order to understand the symbolic
indications of the unconscious
one must be careful not to get outside
oneself or beside oneself
but to stay emotionally within oneself
indeed it is vitally important
that the ego should continue to function
in normal ways
only if i remain an ordinary human being
conscious of my incompleteness
can i become receptive to the
significant contents and processes of
the unconscious
but how can a human being stand the
tension of feeling himself at one with
the whole universe
while at the same time he is only a
miserable earthly human creature
if on the one hand i despise myself as
merely a statistical cipher
my life has no meaning and is not worth
living but if on the other hand i feel
myself to be part of something much
greater
how am i to keep my feet on the ground
it is very difficult indeed to keep
these inner opposites united within
oneself
without toppling over into one or the
other extreme
the social aspect of the self
today the enormous growth of population
especially obvious in large cities
inevitably has a depressing effect on us
we think
oh well i am only so and so living at
such and such an address
like thousands of other people if a few
of them get killed
what difference can it make there are
far too many people in any case
and when we read in the paper about the
deaths of innumerable unknown people who
personally mean nothing to us
the feeling that our lives count for
nothing is further increased
this is the moment when attention to the
unconscious brings the greatest help
for dreams show the dreamer how each
detail of his life is interwoven with
the most
significant realities what we all know
theoretically
that everything depends on the
individual becomes through dreams a
palpable fact that everyone can
experience for himself
sometimes we have a strong feeling that
the great man wants something from us
and has set us very special tasks our
response to this experience can help us
to acquire the strength to swim against
the stream of collective prejudice
by taking our own soul seriously into
account
naturally this is not always an
agreeable task for instance
you want to make a trip with friends
next sunday then a dream forbids it
and demands that you do some creative
work instead
if you listen to your unconscious and
obey it you must expect constant
interference with your conscious plans
your will is crossed by other intentions
intentions that you must submit to
or at any rate must seriously consider
this is partly why the obligation
attached to the process of individuation
is often felt to be a burden rather than
an immediate blessing
saint christopher the patron of all
travelers is a fitting symbol for this
experience
according to the legend he felt an
arrogant pride in his tremendous
physical strength
and was willing to serve only the
strongest first he served a king
but when he saw that the king feared the
devil he left him and became the devil's
servant
then one day he discovered that the
devil feared the crucifix
and so he decided to serve christ if he
could find him
he followed the advice of a priest who
told him to wait for christ to afford
in the years that passed he carried many
people across the river
but once on a dark stormy night a small
child
called out that he wanted to be carried
over the river with the greatest ease
saint christopher lifted the child onto
his shoulders
but he walked more slowly with every
step for his burden became heavier and
heavier
when he arrived in mid-stream he felt as
if he carried the whole universe
he realized then that he had taken
christ upon his shoulders
and christ gave him remission of his
sins and eternal life this miraculous
child is a symbol of the self
that literally depresses the ordinary
human being
even though it is the only thing that
can redeem him in many works of art the
christ child is depicted as
or with the spear of the world a motif
that clearly denotes the self
for a child and a sphere are both
universal symbols of totality
when a person tries to obey the
unconscious he will often as we have
seen
be unable to do just as he pleases but
equally he will often be unable to do
what other people want him to do
it often happens for instance that he
must separate from his group
from his family his partner or other
personal connections
in order to find himself that is why it
is sometimes said
that attending to the unconscious makes
people antisocial and egocentric
as a rule this is not true for there is
a little known factor that enters into
this attitude
the collective or we could even say
social aspect
of the self from a practical angle this
factor reveals itself
in that an individual who follows his
dreams for a considerable time
will find that they are often concerned
with his relationships with other people
his dreams may warn him against
trusting a certain person too much or he
may dream about a favorable
and agreeable meeting with someone whom
he may previously have never consciously
noticed
if a dream does pick up the image of
another person for us
in some such fashion there are two
possible interpretations
first the figure may be a projection
which means that the dream image of this
person is a symbol for an inner aspect
of the dreamer himself
one dreams for instance of a dishonest
neighbor but the neighbor is used by the
dream
as a picture of one's own dishonesty it
is the task of dream interpretation to
find out in which special areas one's
own dishonesty comes into play
this is called dream interpretation on
the subjective level
but it also happens at times that dreams
genuinely tell us something about other
people
in this way the unconscious plays a role
that is far from being fully understood
like all the higher forms of life man is
in tune with the living beings around
him to a remarkable degree
he perceives their sufferings and
problems their positive and negative
attributes and values
instinctively quite independently of his
conscious thoughts about other people
end of side six to continue change side
selector switch and turn the cassette
over
side seven man and his symbols
by carl g young continuing with the
process of individuation
on page 220
our dream life allows us to have a look
at these subliminal perceptions
and shows us that they have an effect
upon us
after having an agreeable dream about
somebody even without interpreting the
dream
i shall involuntarily look at that
person with more interest
the dream image may have deluded me
because of my projections or it may have
given me objective information
to find out which is the correct
interpretation requires an
honest attentive attitude and careful
thought
but as is the case with all inner
processes
it is ultimately the self that orders
and regulates one's human relationships
so long as the conscious ego takes the
trouble to detect the delusive
projections
and deals with these inside himself
instead of outside
it is in this way that spiritually
attuned and similarly oriented people
find their way to one another
to create a group that cuts across all
the usual social and organizational
affiliations of people
such a group is not in conflict with
others it is merely different and
independent the consciously realized
process of individuation
thus changes a person's relationships
the familiar bonds such as kinship or
common interests
are replaced by a different type of
unity a bond
through the self all activities and
obligations that belong exclusively to
the outer world
do definite harm to the secret
activities of the unconscious
through these unconscious ties those who
belong together come together
that is one reason why attempts to
influence people by advertisements and
political propaganda are destructive
even when inspired by idealistic motives
this raises the important question of
whether the unconscious part of the
human psyche can be influenced at all
practical experience and accurate
observations show that one cannot
influence one's own dreams
there are people it is true who assert
that they can influence them
but if you look into their dream
material you find that they do only what
i do with my disobedient dog
i order him to do those things i notice
he wants to do anyhow
so that i can preserve my illusion of
authority
only a long process of interpreting
one's dreams and confronting oneself
with what they have to say
can gradually transform the unconscious
and conscious attitudes also must change
in this process
if a man who wants to influence public
opinion misuses symbols for this purpose
they will naturally impress the masses
in so far as they are true symbols
but whether or not the mass unconscious
will be emotionally gripped by them is
something that cannot be calculated in
advance
something that remains completely
irrational no music publisher for
instance can tell in advance whether a
song will become a hit or not
even though it may draw on popular
images and melodies
no deliberate attempts to influence the
unconscious have yet produced any
significant results
and it seems that the mass unconscious
preserves its autonomy
just as much as the individual
unconscious
at times in order to express its
purposes
the unconscious may use a motif from our
external world
and thus may seem to have been
influenced by it
for instance i have come across many
dreams of modern people that have to do
with berlin
in these dreams berlin stands as a
symbol of the psychic weak spot
the place of danger and for this reason
is the place where the self is apt to
appear
it is the point where the dreamer is
torn by conflict and where he might
therefore be able to unite the inner
opposites
i have also encountered an extraordinary
number of dream reactions
to the film hiroshima in most of these
dreams the
idea was expressed that either the two
lovers in the film must unite
which symbolizes the union of inner
opposites or there would be an atomic
explosion
a symbol of complete dissociation
equivalent to madness only when the
manipulators of public opinion add
commercial pressure
or acts of violence to their activities
do they seem to achieve a temporary
success
but in fact this merely causes a
repression of the genuine unconscious
reactions
and mass repression leads to the same
result as individual repression
that is to neurotic dissociation and
psychological illness
all such attempts to repress the
reactions of the unconscious
must fail in the long run for they are
basically opposed to our instincts
we know from studying the social
behavior of the higher animals
that small groups from approximately 10
to 50 individuals
create the best possible living
conditions for the single animal as well
as for the group
and man seems to be no exception in this
respect
his physical well-being his spiritual
psychic health
and beyond the animal realm his cultural
efficiency
seemed to flourish best in such a social
function
as far as we at present understand the
process of individuation
the self apparently tends to produce
such small groups
by creating at the same time sharply
defined ties of feeling between certain
individuals
and feelings of relatedness to all
people only if these connections are
created by the self
can one feel any assurance that envy
jealousy
fighting and all manner of negative
projections
will not break up the group thus an
unconditional devotion to one's own
process of individuation
also brings about the best possible
adaptation
this does not mean of course that there
will not be collisions of opinion
and conflicting obligations or
disagreement about the right way
in the face of which one must constantly
withdraw and listen to one's inner voice
in order to find the individual
standpoint that the self intends one to
have
fanatical political activity but not the
performance of essential duties
seems somehow incompatible with
individuation
a man who devoted himself entirely to
freeing his country from foreign
occupation
had this dream with some of my
compatriots i go up a stairway to the
attic of a museum
where there is a hall painted black and
looking like a cabin on a ship
a distinguished looking middle-aged lady
opens the door
her name is x daughter of x x was a
famous national hero of the dreamers
country who attempted some centuries ago
to free it
he might be compared to joan of arc or
william tell
in reality x had no children
in the hall we see the portraits of two
aristocratic ladies dressed in flowery
brocaded garments
while miss x is explaining these
pictures to us they suddenly come to
life
first the eyes begin to live and then
the chest seems to breathe
people are surprised and go to a lecture
room where miss
x will speak to them about the
phenomenon she says that through her
intuition and feeling
these portraits came alive but some of
the people are indignant
and say that miss x is mad some even
leave the lecture room
the important feature of this dream is
that the anima figure
miss x is purely a creation of the dream
she has however the name of a famous
national hero liberator
as if she were for instance wilhelmina
tell the daughter of william tell
by the implications contained in the
name the unconscious is pointing to the
fact that today
the dreamer should not try as x did long
ago
to free his country in an outer way
now the dream says liberation is
accomplished by the anima
by the dreamer's soul who accomplishes
it by bringing the images of the
unconscious to life
that the hall in the attic of the museum
looks partly like a ship's cabin painted
black
is very meaningful the black color
hints at darkness night a turning inward
and if the hall is a cabin then the
museum is somehow also a ship
this suggests that when the mainland of
collective consciousness becomes flooded
by unconsciousness and barbarism
this museum ship filled with living
images
may turn into a saving ark that will
carry those who enter it to another
spiritual
shore portraits hanging in a museum are
usually the dead remains of the past
and often the images of the unconscious
are regarded in the same way
until we discover that they are alive
and meaningful
when the anima who appears here in her
rightful role of soul guide
contemplates the images with intuition
and feeling
they begin to live the indignant people
in the dream
represent the side of the dreamer that
is influenced by collective opinion
something in him that distrusts and
rejects the bringing to life of psychic
images
they personify a resistance to the
unconscious that might express itself
something like this
but what if they begin dropping atom
bombs on us psychological insight won't
be much help then
this resistant side is unable to free
itself from statistical thinking
and from extroverted rational prejudices
the dream however points out that in our
time
genuine liberation can start only with a
psychological transformation
to what end does one liberate one's
country if afterward there is no
meaningful
goal of life no goal for which it is
worthwhile to be free
if man no longer finds any meaning in
his life it makes no difference whether
he wastes away under a communist or a
capitalist regime
only if he can use his freedom to create
something meaningful
is it relevant that he should be free
that is why finding the inner meaning of
life
is more important to the individual than
anything else and why the process of
individuation must be given priority
attempts to influence public opinion by
means of newspapers
radio television and advertising are
based on two factors
on the one hand they rely on sampling
techniques that reveal the trend of
opinion or wants
that is of collective attitudes on the
other
they express prejudices projections and
unconscious complexes
mainly the power complex of those who
manipulate public opinion
but statistics do no justice to the
individual
although the average size of stones in a
heap maybe five centimeters
one will find very few stones of exactly
this size in the heap
but the second factor cannot create
anything positive is clear from the
start
but if a single individual devotes
himself to individuation
he frequently has a positive contagious
effect on the people around him
it is as if a spark leaps from one to
another and this usually occurs when one
has no intention of influencing others
and often when one uses no words it is
on to this
inner path that miss x tried to lead the
dreamer
nearly all religious systems on our
planet contain images that symbolize the
process of individuation or at least
some stages of it in christian countries
the self is projected as i said before
on to the second adam christ in the east
the relevant figures are those of
krishna and buddha
for people who are contained in a
religion that is who still really
believe in its content and teachings
the psychological regulation of their
lives is affected by religious symbols
and even their dreams often revolve
around them
when the late pope pius xii issued the
declaration of the assumption of mary
a catholic woman dreamed for instance
that she was a catholic priestess
her unconscious seemed to extend the
dogma in this way
if mary is now almost a goddess she
should have priestesses
another catholic woman who had
resistances to some of the minor and
outer aspects of her creed
dreamed that the church of her home city
had been pulled down and rebuilt
but that the tabernacle with the
consecrated host and the statue of the
virgin mary
were to be transferred from the old to
the new church
the dream showed her that some of the
man-made aspects of her religion
needed renewal but that its basic
symbols
god's having become man and the great
mother the virgin mary
would survive the change such dreams
demonstrate the living interest that the
unconscious takes in the conscious
religious representations of an
individual
this raises the question whether it is
possible to detect a general trend in
all the religious dreams of contemporary
people
in the manifestations of the unconscious
found in our modern christian culture
whether protestant or catholic dr jung
often observed that there is an
unconscious tendency at work to round
off
our trinitarian formula of the godhead
with a fourth element which tends to be
feminine
dark and even evil actually this fourth
element has always
existed in the realm of our religious
representations but it was separated
from the image of god
and became his counterpart in the form
of matter itself
or the lord of matter that is the devil
now the unconscious seems to want to
reunite these extremes
the light having become too bright and
the darkness too somber
naturally it is the central symbol of
religion the image of the godhead
that is most exposed to unconscious
tendencies toward transformation
a tibetan abbot once told dr jung that
the most
impressive mandalas in tibet are built
up by imagination or directed fantasy
when the psychological balance of the
group is disturbed or when a particular
thought cannot be rendered
because it is not yet contained in the
sacred doctrine
and must therefore be searched for in
these remarks
two equally important basic aspects of
mandala symbolism emerge
the mandala serves a conservative
purpose namely to restore a previously
existing order
but it also serves the creative purpose
of giving expression and form to
something that does not yet exist
something new and unique the second
aspect is perhaps even more important
than the first
but does not contradict it for in most
cases
what restores the old order
simultaneously involves some element of
new creation
in the new order the older pattern
returns on a higher level
the process is that of the ascending
spiral which grows upward while
simultaneously returning again and again
to the same point
a painting by a simple woman who was
brought up in protestant surroundings
shows a mandala in the form of a spiral
in a dream
this woman received an order to paint
the godhead
later also in a dream she saw it in a
book
of god himself she saw only his wafting
cloak the drapery of which made a
beautiful display of light and shadow
this contrasted impressively with the
stability of the spiral in the deep blue
sky
fascinated by the cloak and the spiral
the dreamer did not look closely at the
other figure on the rocks
when she awoke and thought about who
these divine figures were
she suddenly realized that it was god
himself
this gave her a frightful shock which
she felt for a long time
usually the holy ghost is represented in
christian art by a fiery
wheel or a dove but here it is appeared
as a spiral
this is a new thought not yet contained
in the doctrine
which has spontaneously arisen from the
unconscious
that the holy ghost is the power that
works for the further development of our
religious understanding
is not a new idea of course but its
symbolic representation in the form of a
spiral is new
the same woman then painted a second
picture also inspired by a dream
showing the dreamer with her positive
animus standing above jerusalem
when the wing of satan descends to
darken the city
the satanic wing strongly reminded her
of the wafting cloak of god in the first
painting
but in the former dream the spectator is
high up somewhere in heaven
and sees in front of her a terrific
split between the rocks
the movement in the cloak of god is an
attempt to reach christ
the figure on the right but it does not
quite succeed
in the second painting the same thing is
seen from below
from a human angle looking at it from a
higher angle
what is moving and spreading is a part
of god
above that rises the spiral as a symbol
of possible further development
but seen from the basis of our human
reality
this same thing in the air is the dark
uncanny wing of the devil
in the dreamer's life these two pictures
became real
in a way that does not concern us here
but it is obvious that they also contain
a collective meaning that reaches beyond
the personal
they may prophesy the descent of a
divine darkness upon the christian
hemisphere
a darkness that points however toward
the possibility of further evolution
since the axis of the spiral does not
move upward
but into the background of the picture
the further evolution will lead neither
to greater spiritual height
nor down into the realm of matter but to
another dimension probably into the
background of these divine figures
and that means into the unconscious
when religious symbols that are partly
different from those we know
emerge from the unconscious of an
individual often feared that these will
wrongfully alter or diminish the
officially recognized religious symbols
this fear even causes many people to
reject political psychology and the
entire unconscious
if i look at such a resistance from a
psychological point of view
i should have to comment that as far as
religion is concerned
human beings can be divided into three
types
first there are those who still
genuinely believe their religious
doctrines whatever they may be
for these people the symbols and
doctrines click
so satisfyingly with what they feel deep
inside themselves
that serious doubts have no chance to
sneak in
this happens when the views of
consciousness and the unconscious
background are in relative harmony
people of this sort can afford to look
at new psychological discoveries and
facts without prejudice
and need not fear that they may be
caused to lose their faith
even if their dreams should bring up
some relatively unorthodox details
these can be integrated into their
general view
the second type consists of those people
who have completely
lost their faith and have replaced it
with purely conscious
rational opinions for these people depth
psychology simply means an introduction
into newly discovered areas of the
psyche
and it should cause no trouble when they
embark on the new adventure
and investigate their dreams to test the
truth of them
then there is a third group of people
who in one part of themselves
probably the head no longer believe in
their religious traditions
whereas in some other part they still do
believe
the french philosopher voltaire is an
illustration of this
he violently attacked the catholic
church with rational argument
a clausee lampham but on his deathbed
according to some reports he begged for
extreme unction
whether this is true or not his head was
certainly
unreligious whereas his feelings and
emotions seem still to have been
orthodox
such people remind one of a person
getting stuck in the automatic doors of
the bus
he can neither get out into free space
nor re-enter the bus
of course the dreams of such persons
could probably help them out of their
dilemma
but such people frequently have trouble
turning toward the unconscious
because they themselves do not know what
they think and want
to take the unconscious seriously is
ultimately a matter of personal
courage and integrity the complicated
situation of those who are caught in a
no man's land between the two states of
mind
is partly created by the fact that all
official religious doctrines
actually belong to the collective
consciousness what freud called the
super ego
but once long ago they sprang from the
unconscious
this is a point that many historians of
religion and theologians
challenge they choose to assume that
there was once some sort of revelation
i have searched for many years for
concrete evidence for the jungian
hypothesis
about this problem but it has been
difficult to find
because most rituals are so old that one
cannot trace their origin
the following example however seems to
me to offer a most
important clue black elk a medicine man
of the oglala sioux who died not long
ago
tells us in his autobiography black elk
speaks
that when he was nine years old he
became seriously ill
and during a sort of coma had a
tremendous vision
he saw four groups of beautiful horses
coming from the four corners of the
world
and then seated within a cloud he saw
the six
grandfathers the ancestral spirits of
his tribe
the grandfathers of the whole world they
gave him
six healing symbols for his people and
showed him new ways of life
but when he was 16 years old he suddenly
developed a terrible phobia whenever a
thunderstorm was approaching
because he heard thunder beings calling
to him to make haste
it reminded him of the thundering noise
made by the approaching horses in his
vision
an old medicine man explained to him
that his fear came from the fact that he
was keeping his vision to himself
and said that he must tell it to his
tribe he did so
and later he and his people acted out
the vision in a ritual
using real horses not merely black elk
himself
but many other members of his tribe felt
infinitely better after this play
some were even cured of their diseases
elk said
even the horses seemed to be healthier
and happier after the dance
the ritual was not repeated because the
tribe was dead soon afterward
but here is a different case in which a
ritual still survives
several eskimo tribes living near the
colville river in alaska
explain the origin of their eagle
festival in the following way
a young hunter shot dead a very unusual
eagle
and was so impressed by the beauty of
the dead bird that he stuffed and made a
fetish of him
honoring him by sacrifices one day
when the hunter had traveled far inland
during his hunting
two animal men suddenly appeared in the
role of messengers
and led him to the land of the eagles
there he heard a dark drumming noise and
the messengers explained that this was
the heartbeat of the dead eagle's mother
then the eagle spirit appeared to the
hunter as a woman clothed in black
she asked him to initiate an eagle
festival among his people
to honor her dead son after the eagle
people had shown him how to do this
he suddenly found himself exhausted back
in the place where he had met the
messengers
returning home he taught his people how
to perform the great eagle festival
as they have done faithfully ever since
from such examples we see how a ritual
or religious custom can spring directly
from an
unconscious revelation experienced by a
single individual
out of such beginnings people living in
cultural groups develop their various
religious activities
with their enormous influence on the
entire life of the society
during a long process of evolution the
original material is shaped and reshaped
by words and actions
is beautified and acquires increasingly
definite forms
this crystallizing process however has a
great disadvantage
more and more people have no personal
knowledge of the original experience
and can only believe what their elders
and teachers tell them about it
they no longer know that such happenings
are real and they are of course ignorant
about how one feels during the
experience
in their present forms worked over
exceed
such religious traditions often resist
further creative alterations by the
unconscious
theologians sometimes even defend these
true religious symbols and symbolic
doctrines
against the discovery of a religious
function in the unconscious psyche
forgetting that the values they fight
for all their existence to that very
same
function without a human psyche to
receive divine inspirations and utter
them in words or shape them in art
no religious symbol has ever come into
the reality of our human life
we need only think of the prophets and
the evangelists
if someone objects that there is a
religious reality in itself
independent of the human psyche i can
only answer such a person with this
question
who says this if not a human psyche
no matter what we assert we can never
get away from the existence of the
psyche
for we are contained within it and it is
the only means by which we can grasp
reality
thus the modern discovery of the
unconscious shuts one door forever
it definitely excludes the illusory idea
so
favored by some individuals that a man
can know spiritual reality in itself
in modern physics too a door has been
closed by heisenberg's
principle of indeterminacy shutting out
the delusion that we can comprehend an
absolute physical reality
the discovery of the unconscious however
compensates for the loss of these
beloved illusions
by opening before us an immense and
unexplored new field of realizations
within which objective scientific
investigation combines in a strange
new way with personal ethical adventure
but as i said at the outset it is
practically impossible to impart the
whole reality of one's experience in the
new field
much is unique and can be only partially
communicated by language
here too a door is shut against the
illusion
that one can completely understand
another person
and tell him what is right for him once
again however one can find a
compensation for this in the new realm
of experience
by the discovery of the social function
of the self which works in a hidden way
to unite separate individuals who belong
together
intellectual chit-chat is thus replaced
by meaningful events that occur in the
reality of the psyche
hence for the individual to enter
seriously into the process of
individuation
in the way that has been outlined means
a completely new and different
orientation toward life
for scientists it also means a new and
different scientific approach to outer
facts
how this will work out in the field of
human knowledge and in the social life
of human beings
cannot be predicted but to me it seems
certain that jung's discovery of the
process of individuation
is a fact that future generations will
have to take into account
if they want to avoid drifting into a
stagnant or even regressive outlook